Guten morgen linus guten morgen oh mann linus ich bin etwas heiser.
Ja man hat gemerkt was in karlsruhe muss es viel sprechen oder.
Deswegen ist meine stimme heute ein bisschen anders okay.
Aux
Logbuch netzpolitik vom siebzehnten januar zwanzig zwanzig in der drei hundertsechsundzwanzig folge.
Man will es nicht meinen tim ist wieder hier im studio,
und hin zum wiederholten mal sachverständige bundesverfassungsgericht in karlsruhe wir hatten das in der letzten sendung ja schon angesprochen und darüber wollen wir uns heute,
ein bisschen unterhalten.
Ach genau.
Das wievielte mal warst du denn da lieber tim.
Ja wir haben versucht gerade nochmal zu rechnen wenn man jetzt nur zählt dass ich auch gesprochen habe also auch sozusagen bei der möglichen anhörungen gehört würde dann war das vierte mal.
Viertes mal als sachverständige.
Ich war noch nie beschwerdeführern oder ich war auch noch nie beschwert.
Du warst an die beschwerdeführer ich hätte ich hätte gedacht beim bei der vorratsdaten.
Stimmt der war ja gut aber da waren wir ja nur zu zu tausenden dabei ja ja richtig.
Lass uns doch mal vielleicht schaffen wir es nur chronologisch ein bisschen zusammenzufassen wie oft du oder mit welchen fällen du denn schon dort was nehmen wir mal an die wo du gesprochen hast.
Einer davor wichtiger das war das gutachten zu den computern da da haben wir zwar nicht gesprochen aber es war die erste große gutachten was glaube ich weil wir uns da viel mühe gemacht haben und auch technisch gut zu erklären auch also,
in einer weise dass jeder verstehen konnte und gutachten auch online gestellt haben dann jetzt war glaube ich der beginn von allem aber gesprochen habe ich das erste mal zur vorratsdatenspeicherung und es ist jetzt ja mittlerweile zehn jahre her,
und dann kam noch die antiterror dabei und dann eine zweite staatstrojaner anhörung also zum gesetz.
Na jetzt ging es um gesetz zum bundesnachrichtendienst also die strategische ausland ausland fernmeldeamt aufklärung wie der beamten schimmel sagt.
Und das war ist die beschwerde ich glaube die erste verfassungsbeschwerde der gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte die jetzt in karlsruhe auch.
Richtig tatsächlich sind ja eine ganze menge die da anliegen aber es ist die erste die jetzt auch besprochen wird aber es ist nicht die erste eingelegt haben aber die erste die auf jeden fall eine mündliche verhandlung hatte und gleich noch eine zweitägige.
Und jetzt müssen wir wollen wir erstens mal ein bisschen darüber unterhalten wie das überhaupt so ist ich denke dass er ein bisschen auch der spannende teil welche rolle hattest du da und.
Es gibt ja sozusagen immer die seite der beschwerdeführer mit ihren bevollmächtigten also praktisch die anwälte und dann gibt's die andere seite das in der regel die bundesregierung,
auf der anderen seite sitzt und die ziehen sich halt sachverständige ran ganz unterschiedliche art viele sind juristen und in diesem fall waren wieder einige technische sachverständige und darunter war ich,
es wird immer so dass man zwar namentlich angeschrieben wird aber über die organisation die man vertritt und und welche natürlich der chaos computer club.
Und die da kam dann einen fragenkatalog
der in der form an ich habe den ja gesehen der lasse ich ein bisschen so als wäre er wahrscheinlich an verschiedene gegangen sie fragen waren nicht so,
nicht so voll spezifisch dass klar war dass die alle jetzt für den pc formuliert waren aber so ein bisschen.
Das ist richtig also das sind dann immer so ungefähr sieben bis zwölf fragen oder sowas in dem dreh und aber dieses mal hatten sie schon so gemacht dass sie gesagt haben also drei spezifische fragen,
bitten wir sie zu beantworten und die hatten dann auch technische aspekte man kann natürlich darüber hinaus gehen denn
da kommt immer ein sehr dicker brief dazu zu weiß ich nicht also acht zentimeter brief weil man ja die ganzen stellungnahmen kriegt auch die antworten die bundesregierung manchmal auch noch andere antworten darauf und es gibt andere gutachten und dann kann man auch zu anderen aspekten stellung nehmen.
Und dann gibst du oder wird ein schriftliche stellungnahme eingereicht.
Genau und man kriegt in der regel eine frist zu einer schriftlichen stellungnahme die hat den umfang den man sich vorstellt
bei uns ist sie natürlich dann auch eher technisch die juristen haben ein bisschen anderer art zu schreiben natürlich wir haben die auch online gestellt also die ist jetzt c d e wie immer es gab noch keine stellungnahme die wir nicht hätten öffentlich gemacht aber wir haben die frisst ein bisschen gerissen,
dann kann man auch mal anrufen und sagen wir schaffen es nicht ganz dürfen wir ein bisschen später abgeben das war hier so und das ist dann auch in ordnung aber nicht alle sachverständigen haben eine schriftliche stellungnahme abgegeben und war das auf welche bei die haben nur gesprochen.
Und das hat mich jetzt so ein bisschen gefragt also man fragt sich ja esel warum gibt's eigentlich den schriftlichen kram ab ich kenne das ja nur vom von diesem bundestags anhörungen da finde ich eigentlich den schriftlichen teil spannender weil der ja bundestags drucksache wird und irgendwie dann halt archiviert wird und hast alles nicht gesehen
und das was man sagt da wirst du jetzt keine also ich meine wenn du in so einem ausschuss bist du wissen mit dem was du sagst jetzt keine,
keine wirkung mehr erzielen das ist ja eh schon eine abgefahrener zu wie ist das beim bundesverfassung.
Er hat ja ich finde den vergleich auf vielen ebenen hinken das liegt vielleicht aber auch an mir an männer etwas zynischen art die mittlerweile gegenüber diesem bundestagsausschüssen entwickelt
habe einfach für mich die erfahrung gelehrt hat dass man wenn man dort zu diesen experten gesprächen geht dass sich viele vorher eigentlich schon,
also man weiß eigentlich dass man nicht viel erreichen.
Ist gelutscht du kannst da jetzt nochmal hingehen du kannst dir nochmal den rasen kaputt treten aber das spiel hast du verloren.
Und das ist halt in karlsruhe nicht so arbeitet ein bisschen ideologischer ist man weiß natürlich auch vorher nicht welche fragen,
die richter stellen die haben auch wirklich ein erkenntnis interesse gerade so im technischen die wollen sich im technische sachverhalte erklären lassen,
manchmal ist uns diesmal diesmal weit vielleicht auch von der struktur der verhandlung ein bisschen anders aber es gibt natürlich auch manchmal,
anhörungen wurde technische so eine große rolle spielt wie zum beispiel damals bei der vorratsdatenspeicherung oder beim staatstrojaner das sind die verhandlungen total dominiert etwa hier so eine mischung,
ich glaube weil nach den,
technischen gutachten war schon klar dass zum beispiel die frage wie gut die deutschen filter funktionieren also so die frage wir kommen nachher nochmal auf den inhalt aber
wie kann der bundesnachrichtendienst deutsch herausfiltern die war eh schon klar weil alle technischen sachverständigen letztlich dasselbe sagen.
Dass es nicht gehen kann.
Außerdem haben wir noch mal voll in die bundesregierung wenn sie spricht versucht natürlich auch immer die themen in eine bestimmte richtung zu drücken das ist hier auch passiert also nicht immer ist es so dass diese ganzen technischen fragen so im mittelpunkt stehen wie du zum beispiel bei der vorratsdatenspeicherung war.
Also und es kommt auch immer noch ein bisschen drauf an wie die verhandlungen geführt wird der sehr formal ist oder ob es wirklich zu so einem dialog kommt.
Und wie war's diesmal also war das das.
Die verhandlungen führt da ja in diesem senat in diesem verwalt herr harbarth
den kannte ich noch nicht das ist der vizepräsident sozusagen und er ist ja sehr umstritten
denn da war ja gerade berufspolitiker und ihm wird ja sogar vorgeworfen dass er mit dem gesetz zu tun hatte denn er war ja stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender der cdu,
und der hatte auch zu tun sozusagen mit diesen rechtsthemen ich weiß auch nicht ob das stimmt und alle waren ein bisschen neugierig so wie würde der die verhandlung führen denn er hat ja gerade sozusagen erst auf diesen richter stuhl gewechselt ist ja durchaus eine kritische sache.
Aber sie hat tatsächlich inhaltlich wenig gesagt er hat wirklich nur so ein bisschen diese verhandlung geführt und die anderen rechte haben fragen gestellt insbesondere der neben ihm sitzende berichterstatter der heißt marting und der wird auch das urteil schreiben.
Das sind wie viele also bundesverfassungsgericht kann mir wenig vorstellen was jetzt irgendwie ein
ich werde es nicht pathetisch werden aber was so der ein heiliger ort der demokratischen auseinandersetzungen eine eigenes verfassungsorgan und du weißt dass da das
das was dort entschieden wird da gibt's jetzt auch gar nichts mehr ne das ist halt das das ist dann das,
gesetz oder der das ist das recht oder dass es das was,
na das ist eben die höchste instanz die wir haben die letzte die die instanz die am ende das allerletzte wort hat.
Es ist auch so ein bisschen diese würde und auch der respektvollen richtern dort also richtig physisch merkbar a weil sie so eine rituale haben das fängt natürlich an mit der kleidung den robben den den mütze.
Eine lustige geräusche lustige rote mützen haben die immer auf.
Ja genau und also sie sie haben sie machen doch nochmal ansagen,
die presse wie lange sie da bleiben wird bis sie rausgeht also es gibt so gewisse rituale aber ist natürlich auch nicht mehr so wie vor zehn jahren wegs zu sagen das erste mal kennengelernt habe weil
ich glaube die generation von richtern die damals da war die ist ja mittlerweile weg die wechseln ja nun alle paar jahre das ist ein,
bisschen lockerer geworden aus meiner sicht,
aber auch derjenige der diese verhandlungen führt der also in der mitte sitzt in diesem fall der stellvertretende was uns gerichtspräsidentin der gibt natürlich auch so ein bisschen immer den ton vor ist ja sehr formal ist ja ein bisschen jovial und aus meiner sicht war der harvard so ein,
im mittelfeld also war nicht sehr streng und auch nicht sehr formal in seiner wortwahl aber er hat auch nicht irgendwie so ein,
er hat schon das wort zugewiesen und das habe ich auch schon anders erlebt also sein vorgänger kirche auf der hattet manchmal auch so ein bisschen laufen lassen da konnte man sich auch mal was zu werfen der hat schon das wort erteilt aber er ist auch.
Wieder war zu werfen heißt man konnte sich ins wort fallen oder.
Ich habe bei dem kirchhoff auch schon mal erlebt dass ich jemand gemeldet hat oder so und,
das kam hier nicht mehr vor aber ich kenne auch noch in andere extrem damals der papier der hatte sehr sehr streng geführt da hat niemand dazwischen geredet also also das ist so ein bisschen abhängig davon wie derjenige der in der mitte sitzt diese verfahren eröffnet.
Aber am ende die im ganzen ist das eigentlich gleich geblieben man hat nachfragen der richter man hatte typische prozedere dass,
die beschwerdeführer zuerst versagen dann sagt die bundesregierung weiter und,
also es gibt schon schon so eine komponente dass die aufeinander anfordern dann wir nachfragen gestellt ich habe es ja nun auch bei anderen höchst gerichten jetzt erlebt das ist nicht überall so,
also mein eigener fall war ja schon mal hier berichtet habe am menschenrechtsgruppen in straßburg da gibt's diese dialogisch element überhaupt nicht,
also dass man wirklich aufeinander anfordern oder dass die richter fragen stellen und sofort wird geantwortet und tut es aber in karlsruhe so das macht es auch intellektuell sehr
interessanter also der erste tag war wirklich toll lang mit vorbesprechung über neun stunden trotzdem hatte mich jedenfalls nicht ermüdet weil,
intellektuell einfach ein interessantes niveau ist nicht alle haben dieses niveau natürlich erreichtet kommt vor.
Ist da wollte ich gerade fragen fragen wie wie also traut sich da auch noch jemand na gut das ist eigentlich eine unsinnige frage aber traut sich da ja auch noch jemand irgendwie unsinn zu behaupten ja ne.
Vor allen dingen.
Man sich dann ja natürlich klar also was was wären jetzt so sagen wir mal beispiele für dreistigkeit.
Naja also ich denke ein gutes beispiel ist hier der herr gauland
der die bundesregierung vertreten hat er hat aus politischen strategischen gründen natürlich ein paar sachen dort vorgebracht die man eigentlich von einem gestandenen juraprofessor nicht erwartet
und betraf gleich am anfang würde ich sagen den ersten themenkomplex und das war natürlich auch kein zufall weil das die presse noch am aufmerksamsten ja man muss ja mal sehen dass man sozusagen die ersten meldungen auch versucht zu dominieren da ging's nämlich um die frage
wem stehen grundrechte zu und es wurde doch relativ lange debattiert und da hat der vertreter der bundesregierung wieland heißt er schon auch also
einfach fakten vorgebracht die man auch im grund studium jura eigentlich nicht mehr erwartet also die frage wem stehen die zu hat er
immer wieder zugespitzt hat auch nicht so richtig geantwortet auf die nachfragen der richter also die frage kann ausländer sozusagen sich oft fernmeldegeheimnis in der deutschen verfassung berufen,
er hat da wirklich immer wieder auch gleich beantwortet.
Und er sagt nein.
Der kam immer der hat insbesondere die präambel der verfassung,
immer wieder zitiert und da steht halt da ist ein territoriale argument drin also natürlich dass die verfassung für die bundesrepublik deutschland oder deutsche volk gilt und dann haben die richter hat nachgefragt na ja aber wie erklären sie sich dann das einige der grundrechte insbesondere,
bestimmte die immer wieder zitiert werden für deutsche sind wenn sie sagen die präambel überall im stehen würde es ist eigentlich keine frage die man debattiert und er hat.
Ich wollte gerade sagen die debattierte doch vor allem nicht mit dem verfassungsrichter oder die haben das wahrscheinlich.
Zu meinen müsstest du ja auch die menschenwürde debattieren und so also insbesondere.
Also ist ja schöne gute mit ihrem grundgesetz und so und habe also wollen wir mal die kirche im dorf lassen und weltraum theorie und habe da alles nicht gesehen.
Na das wurde noch nicht.
Nicht fern.
Das wurde ja nicht so spezifisch sondern er hat wirklich auch teilweise populistische argumente braucht soweit wie axel sozialleistungen also er kann dann so richtig mit argumenten um die.
Die ganz große.
Als wenn dann also irgendjemand auf der welt kommen könnte und sich auf sozusagen so 'ne rechte berufen würde,
natürlich also das haben die richter dann auch der deutliche sagt also asyl oder sozialleistungen ist ja leistungsgerecht eben und bei dem abhören da geht's ja um ein abwehrrechte also die die frage ist ja kann ich wenn eine deutsche behörde,
vom inland,
oder auch vom ausland aus ausländer abhört mich berufen darauf als ausländer und das ist eigentlich eine frage die unter juristen klar entschieden ist das wurde ja auch schon im nsu-untersuchungsausschuss länglich besprochen er brachtet aber aus meiner sicht aus politischen gründen,
auch immer wieder selber argument zu sagen wir können ja die ganze welt sich auf deutsche grundrechte berufen.
Mich interessiert trotzdem noch so ein bisschen das das feeling vor ort also der die verhandlung ging los irgendwann morgens um neun oder.
Es gibt eine um zehn geht's los aber um es gibt eine vorbesprechung für die beteiligten also test die beschwerdeführer die bundesregierung und natürlich auch der bnd und die sachverständigen kommen vorher nochmal zusammen und dann wird sozusagen der tag kurz besprochen wird es schon um neun.
Also stehst morgens auf bis wahrscheinlich am vorabend angereist hotelzimmer da muss man sich was ordentliches anziehen schlafanzughose aus und so ne schuhe an ganze theater und dann.
Stehst du da und.
Na
Am eingang was ist am eingang.
Also wer jetzt noch nie da war also
diese verfassungsgericht liegt im schlossgarten und in der regel sind die beschwerdeführer einfach auch um die der presse ein paar bilder zu liefern machen da oft noch so ein bisschen ja fotomotiv oder so das war an diesem tag auch so ist aber häufig so
und die beteiligten.
Was heißt ein fotomotiv irgendwie ein.
Die hatten das wort aufgebaut ja irgendwie.
Und bei drei sagen wir alle tschüss.
Ein gruppenfoto und dann steht natürlich der presse für kurzes statement zur verfügung und die bundesregierung war mit einer großen gruppe angereist auch der,
präsident karl war angereist dann ist es natürlich so dass die presse sich auch darauf stürzt aber die kam damit fünfzig mann also richtig große gruppe,
jetzt.
Ja ja klar ich meine bei denen geht's auch wirklich um die wurst oder also.
Ja das hat man in der vorberichtserstattung aber schon bemerkt dass also also wenn jetzt alte präsidenten kurz ob
paar tage vor der anhörung quasi durch die presse ziehen und sagen wir werden alle sterben wenn der bmw und seine fähigkeiten beschnitten werden dann weiß man immer schon ja da ist nervosität
die haben halt wirklich die befürchtung dass die richter was beschneiden sie ist auch eine gewisse drohung dahinter glaube ich aber,
in der regel sind halt die beteiligten dann eben früher da als die masse an menschen kommen wir auch voll natürlich können wir auch besucher hin,
um neun schon diese vorbesprechung ist die ist heute auch ein bisschen lockerer also.
Also was die vorbesprechung weil es rund spiel dauert neunzig minuten ich will ein fair.
Ja
Oder oder was sagen die dann.
Ein bisschen erklären sie den ablauf für diejenigen die noch nie da waren sind ja auch immer anwälte da oder sachverständige die gar nicht in ablauf kennen aber die erklären und nochmal wo ihre schwerpunkte liegen worüber sie nicht sprechen wollen,
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das sagen darf in der vorbesprechung weil natürlich es geht um mit bmw gesetzt also das ist natürlich auch mal bereiche die,
geheim sind oder so oder zum beispiel
wenn es darum geht das ganz konkret über die ausleitung der daten gesprochen wird also weiß ich gar nicht ob ich das sagen dürfte das hat mich jetzt nicht betroffen weil ich bin ja sozusagen nicht kein berufs geheimnis.
Dieses thema wo man wo man nicht darüber sprechen darf die ausleitung der daten am am in frankfurt vor.
Der vorteil ist dass dieser fall schon besprochen wurde öffentlich nämlich am bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig und dadurch ergab sich hier nicht so viel so viel probleme weil da einfach da ist ja schon alles gesagt worden und zwar öffentliche.
Das war der teil wo klaus auch dann eigentlich klaus langefeld jahrelang nicht drüber sprechen durfte und inzwischen ist aber.
Müssen wir vielleicht mal erklären also klaus langefeld spricht für den echo und wer ist halt,
oder er ist auch beteiligt natürlich am am keks in frankfurt und an diesem großen knoten ist einer der,
zu sagen ausleitungsfunktionen die kriegen also anordnungen
die früher total geheim waren und jetzt eben wegen der verhandlung am bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig der öffentlichkeit ja schon bekannt sind oder überhaupt die tatsache dass sie da ausleiten.
Dreihundert war zu gast und hat da drüber gesprochen wer ja.
Wirst du bestimmt verlinken oder.
Genau machen wir.
Das mache ich natürlich ich bediene ja die webseite genuss.
Genau du horst ist das ja hier alles und okay dann wird da irgendwie gesagt passt auf freunde wir wir diskutieren hier heute folgende sachen mit dem kram braucht er gar nicht erst zu kommen oder also.
In einer tagesordnung kriegt man vorab geschickt wenn man geladen ist dann weiß man ja schon ungefähr bei glaube dient vor allen dingen der um reizung der zeitschienen also
man muss er sich ungefähr stunden oder halbe stunden überlegen wo passt was rein und dann sagt man aber auch wer wann sprechen soll weil nicht alle sachverständigen zu allem was sagen,
und das ist auch wirklich nochmal erklären.
Der c dann jetzt nicht zu,
nicht zu juristischen kernfragen des verfassungsrechts aber dann irgendwie dass sie dann sagen dann kommt der technische teil frau kurz ab vierzehn uhr dürfen sie dann nicht mehr pipi machen gehen weil dann dann kommt ihr teil oder also sowas kommt dann in der vorbesprechung.
Na ja ein bisschen formaler ist jetzt schon und sie hatten halt einen sachverständigen der war nur einen tag da dann hat man besprochen wie er dass die themen die dort von ihm adressiert wurden am tag eins laufen soweit kommt dann mal vor.
Wieso war der nur ein tag da.
Der hatte eine hochschwangere frau und kam aus dem ausland sodass der nur den einen tag da war.
Okay das.
Also dadurch dass das vorher klar war kann man dann so hinlegen und sowohl gemacht der ist dann sozusagen am ende des ersten tages ist dieser themenkomplex vorgezogen worden.
Okay.
Tatsächlich muss man sich erforschen nicht jeder anwärter waren sind ja teilweise auch junge anwälte bei wissen wie läuft das ist ja auch eine erklärung so so ist hier die struktur und man gibt auch ein bisschen den ton vor glaube ich.
Schon ja ja klar.
Also die richter sitzen da noch nicht in rom und sind noch nicht alle da sondern nur sozusagen der vizepräsident der berichterstatter,
und in diesem fall war es auch noch eine dolmetscher das hatte ich auch noch nicht erlebt also dass man dolmetscht war ja ein sachverständiger kein deutsch sprach.
Aus welchem land kam der.
Okay und dann wird er so vorgesprochen und dann gehen alle raus ihr müsst wieder die richter gehen in die eine richtung raus aber ist ja diese diese komischen hinterzimmer kaputt sind und dann dann musst du vorne wieder durch die.
Erstmal musst du durch ne du hast hinten räume also die sachverständigen und die sind aber getrennt also die beschwerdeführer und die beschwerden und die sachverständigen kriegen unterschiedliche räume da kann man dann seine sachen abstellen jacke hin hängen.
Damit man einfach so damit man irgendwie jeder hat sein eigenes backstage oder oder hat es damit zu tun damit man sich nicht nachher hinten auch noch um die streitet oder oder damit damit damit man das strategische besprechung wahrscheinlich auch.
Ja ich weiß ich nicht genau wie das zustande kommt in der regel sprechen sich die sachverständigen auch abriss wird angeregt man die wollen keine redundanz,
und jetzt sagen sie es wegen die sachverständige hocken zusammen aber auch nicht alle
also zum beispiel die weiteren vertreter vom parlamentarischen kontrollgremium von dem unabhängigen richter gremium die dem bundesnachrichtendienst überprüfen die haben dann anderen raum und liegt aber auch an der größe also kannst du nicht an denselben raum sperren,
ich weiß nicht wie das zustande kommt und kenne ich aber immer so bisher also.
Das das heißt du saßt hauptsächlich im backstage oder oder im.
Na die meisten gehen nochmal raus weil du ja mit der presse interagieren willst und statements abgeben wird sie sind ja da und die haben auch so wagen,
unterschiedlich also manche der sachverständigen möchten gerne kontakt mit der presse andere interessiert es nicht so kann jeder machen wie er will.
Was hast du gemacht.
Beides also ich bin,
noch einmal hinter gegangen aber ich habe dann auch mit der presse geredet klar mein eindruck war dadurch dass wir unsere stellungnahme schon den tag vorher schriftlich gemacht haben war natürlich auch keine überraschung,
mehr in dem was wir argumentativ sagen würden.
Gegenüber der presse oder auch gegenüber den richterin ich wollte gerade sagen die haben ja auch schon länger gehabt ne ja.
Die richter haben das brett sie lesen den richtern die länger vor man wiederholt das auch nicht jetzt sagen die auch noch mal also man.
Die sagen wir haben den stoff gelesen dass klausurrelevante haben wir wir fragen sie jetzt nochmal paar sachen die wir vielleicht vertiefen wollen oder wir wir fragen sie jetzt was wo der sachverständige eins was gesagt hat wo wir ihre meinung nochmal zu hören wollen oder.
Es gibt auch noch einen nicht verbale ebene also muss man sich schon praktisch vorstellen wenn man da sitzt und die verhandlung läuft gibt es manchmal augenkontakt mit den richtern wetter ist wenn irgendwas vorgebracht wird dann,
gibt es manchmal so kontakt.
Dass er da mal kurz auf dich guckt.
Oder auf einer anderen sachverständigen ob also ich glaube auch um klarzumachen ob einer der sachverständigen dazu was sagen will und sehr stark widerspricht das gibt es schon manchmal.
Ob der dann irgendwie augenrollen und irgendwie sagt.
Na oder wenn sich manchmal so man es gibt auch schon manchmal gelächter oder so,
jetzt kommt auch vor also da gibt's noch eine ebene jenseits dieses dialoges also man guckt sich halt auch mal an kommt schon vor zum beispiel also
die richter fragen jetzt auch nicht immer die beschwerdeführer ob sie sprechen wollen ich denke das wird dann auch nonverbal klargemacht dass das dann zum beispiel der
der anwalt der beschwerdeführer durch rübergucken klar macht er wird jetzt nicht dazu gerne auch nochmal außern da gibt's ja nicht immer also da ist schon nochmal eine ebene wo man ja direkt davor der bank sitzt der die gibt's dann war aber auch schon mal stärker,
also denn bei manchen anhörungen die ich erlebt habe da war der widerspruch größer technisch also da hat man sich richtig technisch gestritten.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Staatstrojaner vor allen dingen.
Okay klar das naheliegend dass da office okay und dann aber jetzt nochmal ganz kurz du hast dann jetzt diese neun stunden die das oder die acht stunden die es dann von zehn bis achtzehn.
War schon über neun stunden weil er du fängst früher und also du musst dich auch schon um neun bei der vorbesprechung konzentrieren ja da gibt's ja.
Nee genau aber wenn dann also irgendwann kommt die richter sind das alles richter ne da gibt's auch eine richterin.
Lilly normale mehrere drei frauen waren zwei drei ja drei.
Dann kommen die dann ist ja dieser bekannte moment wo die dann irgendwie in reihe und glied an ihre plätzchen gehen dann stehen sie noch müssen auch alle aufstehen wahrscheinlich ne und dann gucken die und sagen.
Wir nehmen ihre mützen auf und sagen setzen sie sich bitte.
Und setze sie nehmen sie sich bitte platz dann setzt sie sich hin dann wird die sitzung für eröffnet und in dem moment sagst du schon quasi sagst du noch im im backstage oder sagst du schon vorne mit.
Er ist halt sehr pünktlich anfangen fängt dann wirklich um zehn an da so ein gericht dina eröffnet an die tür und sagt das bundesverfassungsgericht und da sitzen die beteiligten also die beschwerdeführer und die sitzen da alle schon.
Hinten steht da einer mit der geige sind das bundesverfassungsgericht tötet.
Früher war das tatsächlich noch krasser weil sie da eine gerichts- die kante die war mehrere jahre da die hatten immer auf eine sehr ich weiß auch nicht auf eine sehr krasse strenge weise gemacht jetzt wartet aber ein anderer mann der das nicht mehr ganz so.
Let's get ready to rumble.
Aber du hast richtig du hast ein hamster du setzt dich da hin und die sorgen auch dafür dass alle pünktlich abläuft und dann sind aber auch noch pressevertreter datest die dürfen noch filmen am anfang
deswegen sieht man diese prozedur immer und dann sitzen aber alles schon gibt aber eine richtig eine vorstellungsrunde,
das heißt jeder einzelne der da sitzt auf den bänken wird dann vorgestellt damit alle wissen wer ist für wen angetreten.
Vorgestellt von.
Von den richtern und dann stehen die jeweils auf also damit auch jeder weiß wer wärst.
Und das sind jetzt nur für die beschwerdeführer und die sich verteidigen also auch für dich.
Ja auch für mich aber hinten beim bnd saß noch welche die nicht vorgestellt wurde,
also ich bin zum beispiel natürlich jetzt also wenn der bvb präsident da sind da personen schützer die erkenntnis mal in kabel der mauer und so also natürlich der ist ja und sie hatten zum beispiel auch noch ein paar,
von der technischen aufklärung des bands die haben sich dann vorgestellt als sie ans pult getreten sind die sind nicht vorgestellt worden in der runde weil sie nicht als technische sachverständige berufen sind aber die haben später fragen beantwortet die die juristen nicht beantworten können.
Verweisen dann b vertreter auf ihre technischen mitarbeiter.
Und dich haben sie dann auch aber aber das ist ja nur also name affiliation-marktplatz und welche.
Die organisation und der.
Feuer hast bei der ganzen angelegenheit.
Und dasselbe ist aber natürlich auch für die beschwerdeführer also die bevollmächtigten sprich die anwälte und aber auch sozusagen die vertreter die da gerade sitzen nicht alle
also hier war natürlich nicht alle beschwerdeführer da sonst wird's noch ein bisschen voll aber du hast nur noch auf der anderen seite sozusagen der bundesregierung dann war zum beispiel eben vertreter des parlamentarischen kontrollgremiums da und so weiter also zum beispiel
ulrich kelber der neue bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte die sitzen ja auch irgendwo die werden dann vorgestellt und so macht man das.
Den vortrag von ulrich kelber schon gesehen auf dem kongress der hat sich sehr freundlich bedank für die einladung fand ich schön.
Ich weiß ich spreche auch kurz mit ihm der hat übrigens bei uns beim kongress können wir ja hier auch mal sagen ein gutes feedback bekommen ich glaube alle sind ein bisschen erleichtert dass er jetzt dieses amt hat ist mein eindruck.
Nächstes nächstes jahr wieder zwei tage kommen ok also ulrich kelber saß auch dabei der war dann.
Es auch selbst gekommen und hat seine vorgängerin nicht immer getan ist natürlich auch ein statement dass der der chef kommt und nicht irgendein mitarbeiter und auch der hat auch gesprochen natürlich.
Als sachverständige.
Ulrich kelber ist in seiner funktion als bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte ein teil der kontrolle des bmw und die kontrolle also überhaupt wie steht im gesetz wie wird dieser nachrichtendienst oder.
Überhaupt kontrolliert.
Genau da ist er natürlich mit zuständig.
Und dann musste er sagen würde sehr viel kontrollierst du denen dann sagt er ich frage die dann sagen die geh weg.
Nee also hatte er schon eine strategie stellungnahme abgegeben sein haus viel mehr da geht's aber vor allen dingen auch um kritik also wie,
sind die lücken in der kontrolle also das ist nicht nur ein erfassen was es wirklich was passiert da sondern auch wo sind defizite.
Ja und das das sagt er dann da.
Da gibt's auch ein dialogisch element der sascha die ganze zeit da und er hört natürlich zu und dann nimmt man auch mal bezug zu dem was davor gesagt wurde hat schon wirklich es ist auch ein bisschen ein gespräch ja also keins wo sich
einer ins wort fällt aber es gibt bezug zu dem was vorher gesagt wurde und die allermeisten hier sitzen sind sehr aufmerksam auch das publikum übrigens also.
Ist ja auch hier ipad und internet verbot.
Richtig und heute würde jetzt anders gemacht als ich vorher immer noch könnte das sagt jemand an und es gibt auch eine gewisse drohung,
wenn jemand dabei erwischt hat muss er den saal verlassen und das haben die früher so nicht angesagt jetzt wird es angesagt es gibt aber ausnahmen die auf den bänken vorne sitzen können,
wenn sie zum beispiel plädoyer ablesen oder mit tippen wollen auch rechner benutzen sie sollten aber auch vielleicht sein muss man aber vorher ansagen.
Damit er nicht damit er nicht die ganze zeit getwittert wird oder aber weil annabis sally hat ja geliked blog da habe ich mich gefragt wie sie das irgendwie hingekriegt hat.
Oben auf der pressewand die ist so ein bisschen erhöht sieht ein bisschen anders aus mittlerweile ich denke,
ich denke nicht dass sie da großartig was dagegen haben mittlerweile also man sieht auf einmal hochgucken die pressevertreter haben im prinzip alle rechner,
das ist aber auch nicht das erste mal gewesen mir scheint dass die richter dagegen nichts haben sonst hätten sie ja was dagegen unternehmen können war ja vollkommen klar wer das tut es aber eben bei der anderen in dem saal geht's natürlich sicherlich auch nochmal um bitte.
Die gibt es nicht.
Gibt es vom gerichtshaus.
Mit mitschnitt oder oder stenographie.
Es gibt einen mitschnitt der später transkribiert wird sagen sie auch an uns am anfang wird angesagt dass sozusagen alles was hier gesagt wird zu protokoll gegeben wird,
das ist auch richtig so aber ich hab diese noch nie gesehen denke die also veröffentlicht werden die nicht weiß nicht ob die beschwerdeführer die bekommen ich denke da hat er was damit zu tun
dass du wirklich auch für die urteilsfindung nachher nochmal die argumente anhören kannst würde ich vermuten.
Ich bin ja also was mich noch so was ich wirklich versuche daraus zu hören ist wieviel.
Wie viel.
Steckt jetzt wirklich noch in dieser anhörung drin von der wirkung weil am ende ne ich meine die werden sich ja jetzt nicht die richter und richterin die da hängen werden jetzt nichts sagen hör mal,
die kurz die war pfiffig die die der tim der war pfiffig,
was was der so gesagt hat das fand ich echt ganz sympathisch ich würde sagen der gehen wir jetzt den pc mann punkt so ne.
Nee also ich würde mal sagen mir schienen in dieser anhörung auch so dass die technischen fakten gar nicht so umstritten waren,
man muss man muss seine die ganze verfahren sehen es gibt die beschwerde die sehr,
lesbar und ganz viele verfassungsrechtliche probleme aufwirft und es gibt dann noch mal zu sagen
im dialog dazwischen die bundesregierung antwortete gibt auch noch andere staatsregierung die dort gutachten abgeben in diesem fall bayern dann gibt es nochmal eine antwort des beschwerde für uns es gibt ja ein schriftliches verfahren wo die ganz klar
wirklich gute argumente machen in diesem verwaltet matthias becker der einfach so sehr lesbar verfassungsbeschwerde geschrieben hat ganz klar das herausgearbeitet hat wo ich hier verfassungswidrige stellen sind ja und darauf beziehen sie sich ja schon das wird ja nicht alle wiederholt,
und die verhandlung dient der klärung von er gerade zu diesem offen gebliebenen stellen das sind wenige technische hier gewesen natürlich kann man als technischer sachverständiger manchmal einen punkt setzen,
an
ich hätte zum beispiel ein paar argumente die mir wirklich auch während dieser stunden aufheben die gänge ja nicht sagen wollte die auch natürlich in dem gutachten nicht drin sind aber ich habe auch nicht wiederholt weil wir hier schon schriftlich geschrieben haben
und das war aus meiner sicht auch nicht abstreiten das ist vollkommen klar dass es eine fehlerrate gibt wenn man versucht deutsche,
herauszufiltern das ist einfach technisch sehr leicht zu begründen.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich wird auch das verfassungsgericht sich jetzt mit der frage beschäftigen wie viel fehlerrate lass finden wir den akzeptabel oder also die werden ja
am ende müssen sie auch wahrscheinlich eine abwägung machen da werden sie eine abwechslung machen dass sie sagen ja okay fehlerrate gibt es
ist unbestritten haben wir bei allem anderen auch wir tun leute in sicherheitsverwahrung die da nicht hingehören wir wir verurteilen leute mit fehlerrate zu für straftaten die sie nicht begangen haben wir lassen leute mit fehlerrate frei für irgendwas ne dass sie irgendwie sagen so
fehler haben wir und.
Ja
Mit allen gesetzen bemühen wir uns das so das ziel so gut wie möglich zu erreichen.
Na ja jetzt mal nicht diesem diesem diesem bisschen,
er wird jetzt auch gerne in der presse so aufhören obwohl sitzt dem mann nicht auf wir reden über ein auslandsgeheimdienst ne erstmal soll der ja im inland gar nichts,
und dass man diesen auslandsgeheimdienst aber auch ein bisschen warm nimmt als jemand der mit der inneren sicherheit zu tun hat es ist ja eigentlich schon ein argument müsste man hinterfragen.
Ja also wenn ihr zum beispiel jemanden zum beispiel da kommt der vorsitzende des parlamentarischen untersuchungs-oder parlamentarischen gremiums wird die kontrolle übernimmt also pkk,
als erstes bringt dir das beispiel breitscheidplatz dann ja dann ist es natürlich dann ist man schon wieder gefangen in diesem falle dass man sich sagt okay was hat jetzt mal nochmal diese auslandsgeheimdienst damit zu tun ja so eigentlich sind die ja nicht dafür zuständig.
Aber es ist halt sein sein bestes passwort.
Ich glaube die wahrnehmung hat sich so hin gedreht ja die viele nehmen den bären die auch im sinne der inneren sicherheit ware,
eigentlich ist er aber ein auslandsgeheimdienst also so muss man sich natürlich eigentlich auch die beispiele konstruieren andererseits ist es natürlich schon so dass es mit der inneren sicherheit zu tun haben kann.
Klar insbesondere wenn man davon ausgeht dass das anis amri jemand war der irgendwann aus dem ausland nach deutschland kam der sich eigentlich dort erst
wirklich radikalisiert hat also es ist klar dass ein fließender übergang ist zwischen inlandsgeheimdienst und auslandsgeheimdienst ins.
Normalerweise wäre das nicht so richtig die zuständigkeit des bnd,
die klassischen beispiele da gebracht worden war natürlich auch bundeswehr beispiele also dass man versucht soldaten vor anschlägen zu schützen aber die wurden dort nicht sehr
gewalzt weil diese
die bundeswehr frage von vornherein relativ weit abgeschnitten wurde haben die richter auch gesagt das ist nicht also das ist nicht der kern dieses verfahrens aber normalerweise geht es ja darum irgendeinen ihre kommuniziert mit einem amis,
das ist ja auslands auslands aufklärung.
Unsere feinde halten.
Sie sollen jetzt die sonne herausfiltern dass sie eben keine deutschen erwischen also man wurde schon immer auch vermischt,
geh doch ein bisschen darum wie sich der bnd versteht das wurde auch konkret gefragt auf den bnd-präsidenten der ja anwesend war versteht er sich zu sagen nur als strategischer,
aufklärer oder muss er informationen vor allen dingen beifang oder was er dabei entdeckt während er das strategisch abhört eben auch weiterreichen an die zuständigen behörden das war durchaus auch thema.
Und was hat er da gesagt.
Na ja sie können,
sie können sich ja nicht so positionieren als wenn sie für diese für diese innenbereich zuständig sind obwohl alle sie so wahrnehmen es war so ein bisschen so ein bisschen um den heißen brei rumlaufen ja,
sind sie nun dienstleister oder nicht der auch für die innere sicherheit man hat sich das ein bisschen also
der präsident so ein bisschen drum herum gewundert zu sagen die beziehen sich immer wieder auf das sogenannte auftragsprozesse die bundesregierung vergibt an den bnd ein zentrales auftragsprozesse nachdem er handelt dieses ist aber natürlich sehr vage,
ja so wie im gesetz ja auch sehr vage ist was die aufgaben des bmw.
Was würde in dem auftragsbuch viel drinstehen.
Insbesondere die die länder die interessant sind die bundeswehr auslandseinsätze kann aber natürlich auch personenbezogen sein aber sicherlich nicht im auftragsprozesse weil da stehen eher so die großen linien also wir müssen wissen was dem jemen vorgeht,
wir müssen wissen wer in afghanistan läuft und dieses auftragsprozesse da ist,
das ist natürlich erstmal die richter kennen eins aber ich glaube öffentlich bekannt sind die aktuell nicht man weiß nur so um gehoben was da drin steht.
Ja also man kann sich man kann sich relativ klar aus der interessenlage der bundesrepublik deutschland und ihrer regierung ableiten.
Ich habe mal meine zettel also ich habe ja auf zettelchen geschrieben der karl also der präsident hat zum beispiel ganz ganz klar gesagt unser thema ist das ausland ja,
ja also auch wenn die wahrnehmung eben bisschen anders sind ja.
Wenn man ihnen auftragsbücher weiter mein thema war dann dann sagte er oder hat er sagt wir sind halt empfänger befehlsempfänger in diesem sinne von diesem auftragsprozesse so also,
er muss sich ja doch irgendwie als nachrichten aufbereitung behörde hinstellen kann ja nicht sagen wir hören die leute ab.
Wir sind ja jetzt so wie selbstverständlich drüber gegangen vielleicht sollten wir einmal noch wirklich die beschwerde selbst in ihren kernpunkten also es geht klar die ausland ausland,
fernmeldeamt aufklärung spezifisch die rolle beifang von deutschen,
grundrechtsträger oder.
Aber eine der fragen das ist spezifisch die auf die du dich jetzt auch am meisten oder in der du die größte rolle gespielt hast.
Die haben halt ein bisschen anders strukturiert orientiert sich immer so ein bisschen an den juristischen schemata also einmal ging es darum ist diese verfassungsbeschwerde zulässig das ist tatsächlich also man.
Muss auch immer erstmal geklärt werden.
Eher richtig das bestreitet die bundesregierung und dann muss man erklären.
Warum was ist daran nicht zulässig.
Die bundesregierung hat argumentiert dass die beschwerdeführer also die journalisten die sich hier beschwert fühlen gar nicht,
einfach nicht nach karlsruhe wenden können sondern sie hätten ja zum beispiel hat
der vertreter der bundesregierung argumentiert sie hätten ja auch beim bnd fragen können ob sie erfasst und dann sagt der nein und dann werdet erledigt also man muss begründen warum man direkt nach karlsruhe ziehen kann also die sogenannte zulässigkeit aber auch da waren auch so eine frage noch juristische natur wieder zitieren gebote
also das bedeutet dass in dem gesetz muss stehen welche grundrecht ist hier betroffen da steht da nicht,
die verfassungswidrig also da muss drin stehen wir greifen hier in das grundrecht der fernen des fernmeldegeheimnis ein artikel zehn besteht ja nicht,
und diese zitiere gebot musste eigentlich drinstehen aber da die bundesregierung bestreitet dass ausländer,
ein fernmeldegeheimnis haben ist es nicht drin also so in so 'ne sache die man jetzt.
Die man jetzt als normal also als nicht jurist sagen würde so hallo.
Leidet jetzt schon sehr grundsätzlich unterschiedliche positionen das war nicht immer so also in anderen verhandlungen waren die näher einander dran also dass die also grundsätzlich bestreiten dass die journalisten oder die vertreter jetzt reporter ohne grenzen,
zulässig einer verfassungsbeschwerde einlegen und ist nicht immer so aber,
im zweiten punkt ging es dann um die datenerhebung also um diese massenüberwachung aber auch um die kontrolle der
um die datenweitergabe an andere geheimdienste also da kommen dann noch andere komplexe punkte die von die mit dem technischen bezug waren vor allen dingen die massenüberwachung der filter
also wie kann man filtern sinnvoll aber außer der überwachung natürlich und dann wie würdet kontrolliert
wie ist die datenweitergabe an anderer geregelt im gesetz sehr soweit alle also da ist ja eine menge rausgekommen über den nsu-untersuchungsausschuss wo man schon gemerkt hat dass,
eben teilweise im raum mit schwankt.
Daten weitergabe und daten teilen okay das ist für die also für dich wahrscheinlich das thema zu dem du relativ wenig auskunft.
Ging es im wesentlichen bei uns um die daten als den technischen um die datenerhebung und die filterung.
Und wenn aber die datenweitergabe da geht's ja dann das geht ja dann in richtung des buches der ja also auch ein begriff der im nsu-untersuchungsausschuss sehr häufig gefallen ist das quasi,
kurz.
Auf die spitze getrieben auslandsgeheimdienst a darf seine bürger nicht überwachen auslandsgeheimdienst bäder seine bürger nicht überwachen wenn sie aber einfach miteinander tauschen kriegen können sie sich quasi gegenseitig beide die daten geben die sie selber nicht erfassen dürfen,
das ist ja auch eine eine super krasse sache weil der hat ja der bnd auch immer angst.
Wenn sie nicht mehr erfassen dürfen das ist ja sogar etwas was auch offen gedroht wird regelmäßig werden ja unsere sicherheitsbehörden damit erpresst primär von amerikanern dass gesagt wird pass auf wir teilen nicht mehr mit euch wenn ihr nicht,
wenn ihr nicht das und das erfasst oder wenn ihr jetzt was weiß ich wenn ihr die telekom kaufen lasst dann schicken wir euch keine intelligence briefing mehr das heißt die der bnd würde ja jetzt,
das scheint ja für den bmw durchaus auch ein problem zu sein wenn den jetzt gesagt wird pass auf die daten die ihr da fast dürft ihr auch nicht mit anderen teilen dann haben die irgendwie nichts mehr womit sie an den verhandlungstisch gehen können,
aber das ist eher eine das wurde dann eher unter juristen ausgehandelt.
Also aus meiner sicht war das schon auch ein zentraler punkt aber der ist natürlich komplex zum einen weil wir darüber jetzt eine menge wissen,
das wissen wir durchs norden wir wissen es aber auch durch den untersuchungsausschuss wir wissen eine menge das einfach 'ne menge rausgekommen insbesondere rechtswidrige aktionen wie total oder regional ja also wir wissen dass der bnd geheim abkommen geschlossen hat die,
man rechtswidrig nennen kann und das ist ja auch der grund warum diese einsatz eigentlich entstanden ist sie haben ja,
tätigkeiten die rauskam legalisiert durch das gesetz und jetzt ist die frage ob der verfassungsgemäß ist,
und da hängt er noch mehr mehr zusammen die sprechen ja auch darüber da hat es durchaus auch also es ist nicht so dass die bundesregierung das nicht auch argumentiert oder der vertreter der bundesregierung oder auch der präsenz und sagt das ist ein einem wasser an,
sozusagen die wir tauschen oder in ein tausch objekt die wir anbieten.
Ja ja und wir können uns nicht darauf verlassen dass andere ausländische geheimdienste nur informationen uns geben sondern wir müssen die auch gegenchecken und wir brauchen eine verhandlungsmasse aber es bleibt dir dabei dass du geheimer gekommen sind,
ich möchte nochmal daran erinnern,
die zentrale behörde die aufsicht über den bnd hat nämlich die bundeskanzleramt hat sich im untersuchungsausschuss immer ahnung du sie geben das war damals steinmeier,
der damals ja bundeskanzleramt treffer der hat gesagt er wusste von gar nichts weil ja die geheimdienste miteinander geheim abkommen machen,
ob das stimmt wissen wir wissen nicht ob der steinmeier wirklich keine ahnung hatte aber das ist letztlich so geblieben das heißt sie könnten auch jetzt wieder solche abkommen treffen,
und dafür hatten die eben genau diesen britischen sachverständigen denn er hat ja auch ein bisschen darüber gesprochen wie
die gesetzesnovelle in großbritannien war dass dort also eine sehr viel bessere kontrolle ist und dass man trotzdem noch zu sagen in der internationalen liga mitspielen kann dazu haben sie natürlich
technisch relativ gut gemacht dass sie sich ein sehr viel potential landesvertretung als britische behörde später der anderen liga als jn und trotzdem könne man sozusagen mit einem strengeren,
gesetz noch leben wird war schon nicht nicht uninteressant dass sie sich gerade einen briten eingeladen haben.
Aber bei der regierungsseite oder war der.
Der vertreter war ein ehemaliger menschenrechtsanwälte der jetzt bei der sogenannten arbeitet das ist eine neue behörde die der kontrolle dient aus meiner sicht hat er.
Sorry powers.
Das ist eine ernste commission da also wie so eine art ja beauftragter für die kontrolle ist aber eine kleine behörde dieses neue schaffen worden also die ist mit der novellierung in großbritannien neu geschaffen worden.
Also im weitesten sinne ein britischer behördenvertreter der der vom deutschen verfassungsgericht dem.
Erklärt hat.
Nd an die karre bist.
Nee der hat erstmal erklärt wie es in großbritannien läuft das hat er nicht sekret aus meiner sicht als nicht sehr kritische tani bin da aber sicherlich,
subjektiv denn ganz sicher gibt es dafür sehr viel kritischere stimmen als der gebracht hat der hatte tatsächlich aus meiner sicht zumindest relativ regierungsfeindlich erklärt aber trotzdem hat er erstmal erklärt,
wie ist das neue kontrolle in bezug auf den geheimdienst in großbritannien und der ist nun mal tatsächlich sehr viel also sowohl vom personal wie vom geld und auch vom von den abhören möglichkeiten sehr viel größer.
Und und die die die anbindung das ja auch nicht vergessen.
Naja liegt ja auch ein bisschen daran wir wissen ja meinen dass die
temporär programm haben also dass sie einen großen teil der daten über die glasfaserkabel die unterirdisch zu sagen im ozean verlaufen abhören und wie sie es machen müssen wir durch die durch die snowy veröffentlichung auch ist mittlerweile auch unbestritten
da ich ja selber diesen fall vom europäischen menschenrechtsrat zur farbe kenne ich sehr viel kritischere position aber wir haben ja die beschwerde gegen die alte gesetz,
der zieht sich ja schon seit fünf jahren.
Erstaunlich wie sich diese gesetze alle ändern und dann diese bnd gesetz verfassungsbeschwerde ist aber gegen das neue gesetz welches eine reaktion
war auf den zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen ein untersuchungsausschuss.
Es war eigentlich eine frechheit dass sie sozusagen den abschlussbericht nicht abgewartet haben sondern die novelle vorher gemacht haben.
Gesagt haben ja lass dir mal wir machen schon mal so wir sehen da schon die probleme die uns jetzt irgendwie kommen wir was wir nochmal legalisieren müssen alles damit das.
Also aus meiner sicht haben die vor allen dingen die cdu vertreter die sehen das ergebnis des bnd versuchen sie auch schon ganz anders,
muss man jetzt soll ich sagen der abschluss debatte dann da war bmw gesetzt ja schon beschlossen aber die die sehen keine massenüberwachung die haben keine rechtswidrigkeit erkannt die haben richtig eine andere weltsicht,
da getan.
Ich glaube in einem sendung titel haben wir das mal zusammengefasst als das gesetz verstößt gegen die geheimdienste.
Da scheint so die cdu position zu sein oder.
Wenn man das jetzt mal so ein bisschen über,
also so ein bisschen dieses image des bnd betrachtet über letzten jahre der hatte ja schwer zu kämpfen ja der schindler müsste zurücktreten der der ganze ausschuss hat sich auf den bnd eingeschossen aber ich denke mal der peak ist da erreicht,
ich glaube so kritisch wie zu der hochzeit des ndr untersuchungsausschusses wird er heute nicht mehr betrachtet sonst hätten glaube ich auch,
jetzt so die ehemaligen präsidenten die sich im vorhinein da geäußert haben über die presse nicht mehr so doll,
drohen können also mein eindruck ist dass der heute nicht mehr ganz so kritisch gesehen wird wie noch als da irgendwie jede zweite woche irgendeine peinlichkeit rauskam,
über die funktionsträgern theorie oder die weltraum theorie wurde da auch nicht mehr gesprochen das hatten die richter vollkommen klar gemacht wissen wir das brauchen wir nicht nochmal ausführen hat auch niemand also es gibt bestimmte sachen die da nicht noch mal angesprochen werden.
Also weil sie weil die richter sagen für ihr urteil muss das doch eine rolle spielen oder nicht.
Ja aber das wird dann nicht nochmal wiederholt weil jeder weiß was damit gemeint ist ja also das ist so ein bisschen.
Seien sie quasi diese ganze diese ganze brauchen wir auch nicht mehr zu diskutieren freunde wir sind hier.
Das ist schon auch eine frage damit das niveau ist einfach hoch aber alle die da sitzen,
also jetzt die beteiligten und ich glaube auch ein großteil des publikums hat natürlich auch wirklich eine juristische idee war da besprochen wird du fängst dann nicht nochmal zu sagen beim grundstudio um an das macht's aber auch so spannend da zu sitzen das ist natürlich sehr anstrengend,
weil sehr wenige pausen gibt und sehr lang ist aber trotzdem ist intellektuell entspannt.
Davon was trinken.
Das ist tatsächlich ein problem die beteiligten also sozusagen wir vorne auf den bänken wir kriegen wasser aber die hinten ja ich habe auch schon,
also auch da mit dem publikum besprochen ist manchmal sehr lang ohne ohne getränk aber man bringt er ja nicht mehr drin ich glaube dass manche leute vielleicht eine wasserflasche dabei haben aber man muss da publikum muss durch eine kontrolle wie am flughafen.
Hier nicht.
Waren's beteiligten haben auch anderen eingang.
Der rest der man nicht damit ist also das heißt dass du hättest.
Also ja.
Eine wasserflasche mit hätte es locker eine wasserflasche mit reinnehmen.
Ja sozusagen die beteiligten haben da gewisse.
Der sollte sich mal ein geheimdienst drum kümmern können die sicherheit werden so überlegen dass ja so einen anarchisten wie dich irgendwie rein.
Sagst du nur ungern minus aber zum beispiel auch was ich nicht mehr im bundeskanzleramt so wenn man da eingeladen wird dann muss man nicht durch die flughafenkontrolle ich weiß nicht warum ich denke aber,
gericht ist natürlich gut geschützter da stehen richtig polizisten mit großem waffen die auch ein bisschen dafür sorgen dass sozusagen diese würde des gerichtes auch wenn man da ein fototermin mit der presse hat und so da,
eingehalten wird da stehen ja richtig dickes bundespolizei wenn ihr interpretiert habt also die geben sich schon mühe auch alle da geordnet laufen zu lassen.
Das hat keine bonbonpapier auf der straße liegt.
Ja und dass man auch nicht warum steht wo man nicht so stehen hat also das ist ja so ein bisschen eingezäunt da und da ist auch drin die polizei man muss da auch ausweis zeigen oder ein paar zeigen wenn man da reingeht dann
sozusagen sachverständige oder als anwalt als bevollmächtigter muss man sich da vorher ja melden man sagt ja man kommt zu der zu der ladung.
Findet auch ans merkwürdig wenn die beschwerdeführer dadurch sucht würden wäre irgendwie komisch oder.
Ja
Weiß nicht also da ich diese.
Wer auf jeden fall für für ein attentat echt ein long shot ding anzustrengen und aber naja also ich glaube den geht's ja auch also ich würde ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass es den um unmut begründung oder sonstige verletzungen der.
Nee nee die sagen auch mal weil es gibt ja mal 'ne husten oder ein lachen das kommt schon vor aber meistens nur wenn jemand sich mal verstoppt dort wird auch durchaus mal ein richter sein kann also dann gibt's auch mal gelächter die leute hören schon sehr aufmerksam zu.
Ich dachte jetzt eher sowas was ja im bundestag auch nicht das ist demonstrieren also dass keine plakate aufhängen oder so.
Ich hab's noch nie erlebt in karlsruhe.
Nee das finde ich jetzt sehe auch ach so dass das jemand der sehr auch ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen irre aus ne wenn da alles irgendwie vollhängt mit irgendwie plakaten oder.
Na sie sorgen auch ein bisschen dafür dass da draußen vom gericht nicht zum klamauk wird.
Also man muss einen gewissen abstand halten denn eigentlich haben die beschwerdeführer auch immer irgendwie so ein bisschen,
aufbauten für die presse mitglieder zu fotografieren haben wir haben ja damals mal große zwei meter fährt also damals den staatstrojaner dahin transportiert nach karlsruhe einfach für ein fotomotiv
dann sorgen die aber schon dafür dass es nicht zu klamaukig wirklich muss man ein stück weggehen haben wir auch gemacht damals.
Den trick mit dem trojanischen pferd kennen die.
Ich saß aber drauf.
Das steht noch glaube ich im lager bei uns okay so jetzt also wir haben ein bisschen darüber gesprochen es geht um,
dein also es geht um die weitergabe der daten es geht um also das weitergeben und teilen die erhebung generell das filtern der daten als besonderes thema weil ja quasi die filterung,
die voraussetzung dafür ist dass die erhebung dieser daten überhaupt stattfinden könnte so also wenn.
Die erfassung ist schon der erste eingriff ne also das ist immer der zweite schritt ist dass du sie filter ist auch die.
Genau aber das dass sie sie überhaupt filtern ist ja schon der also wenn angenommen es gäbe keine filter dann dürften sie,
könnten sie noch nicht mal erheben und die position die ja jetzt denke ich also vom c erstens vertreten wird und zweitens auch korrekt vertreten wird ist das.
Vielleicht,
diese idee mit einem kommunikationspartner ist in deutschland ein anderer nicht in sogenannten circa switch networks also in,
den klassischen telefonvortrag es gibt ein kabel von deutschland nach,
frankreich ja wo über mehrere switches
er hat früher in mechanischer natur tatsächlich letztendlich ein signal über verschiedene drähte und käbelchen und so wirklich in frankreich ankommt und dieses kabel,
läuft auch nur von deutschland nach frankreich während wir jetzt in den packet switch networks eben,
wildes bdp haben also wilde routen zuweisungen unklar es ist nicht vorhersagbar über welche länder ein paket geht zumal jetzt natürlich noch hinzu kommt,
dass wenn jetzt eine deutsche person mit einer deutschen person sich e-mail schreibt die beide theoretisch,
internationale e-mail provider nutzen können ja einen französischen und einem britischen oder so ne so das unter umständen in den datenpaketes,
sowieso nicht erkennbar sein kann dieses ist nun ein dort ein paket eines deutschen kommunikationsverbot oder so.
Naja vielleicht schon aber da musst du halt reingucken und den inhalt den inhalt zu analysieren wäre ja ein weiterer eingriff ich will mal vorher anfangen also,
der tv hat seit langem die position die ja auch glaube ich schon seit,
der dicke schon seit der vorratsdatenspeicherung immer wieder vertritt dass eine anlasslose massenüberwachung keine,
position ist die die wir langfristig hinnehmen wollen egal was für eine art von daten ist der damit fängt's an das ist ja die erfassung aber du hast jetzt sehr abgestellt auf zu sagen die was passiert danach
das sind aber unterschiedliche eingriffe die bindung unterschiedlich behandelt.
Ich hätte jetzt nur verstanden dass diese filterung danach überhaupt die legitimation dafür ist das überhaupt die verfassung geben kann weil das die erfassung so nicht geht ist eigentlich wäre unstrittig oder habe ich das.
Wenn die im urteil sagen man darf keine massenhafte anlasslose erfassung mehr sagen dann nehmen wir mal eine pullover machen weil sie ja dass sie sozusagen in rohdaten strom nicht mehr haben dürfen.
Ohne unabhängig von.
Also wie gesagt man muss sich mal ein bisschen unterscheiden da ist ja auch noch im bereich also es ist einmal die erfassung dann ist es die weiterverarbeitung schaffen sie den einen ordentlichen filter ja dann gibt es aber auch noch den kernbereich,
der sogenannte kernbereich der privaten lebensgestaltung also wird dabei auch in
höchstpersönliches eingegriffen in den teams wäre wie wie kann man das aussortieren das sind also immer noch unterschiedliche problembereiche und dann kommen die weitergabe wir sind da für die bedingungen wer kontrolliert das das eingehalten wird also sind ja richtig unterschiedliche komplexe.
Im technischen haben wir natürlich einmal diese wat du erwähnt hast also die packt typische paket vermittelte kommunikation erklärt aber,
auch nochmal darauf hingewiesen dass wir eigentlich nicht mehr nur pferde melde gehaltenes reden sondern dass es viel mehr ist als kommunikation das ist
letztlich ein einblick in bewegungsprofile aber ein bisschen wie bei der vorratsdatenspeicherung ja aber auch in diesen alltag und es kann auch maschine maschine kommunikation sein nicht alle es unbedingt von den menschen getriggert oder des menschmaschine also da sind mehr sachen als,
wenn man mal durchdenkt tut sich eine menge auf.
Ein einfaches beispiel was ich ganz gerne verwende wenn wenn mein computer aufklappt und mit einem internet verbunden wird gewählt er ein bestimmtes profil an mailserver an,
so das was was ihn quasi sofort erkennbar macht einfach weil das verschiedene mailserver sind die in ihrer kombination im zweifelsfall nur ich nutze also ein,
letztendlich ein fingerprint meines computers der über den sich ein weltweites tracking sofort realisieren lässt ne
büchsen die die in in der folge folgende request machen und zu diesen verbinden und dann da sockel aufhalten ganz klarer punkt wie du meinen computer aus einem weltweiten datenströme sofort identifizieren,
und dann nimmst du die source dann weißt du wo ich mich lang bewegt habe ne.
Jetzt frage ich dich sozusagen die juristen dann fragen ist das zu sagen personenbezogen.
Dein beispiel wenn ihr mit kennt nicht bleiben jetzt werde ich zum beispiel personenbezogen.
Würden wahrscheinlich genau das recht dann müsste ich sagen nein weil diese mälzer wir könnten ja auch andere nutzen aus aus deren sicht.
Deine e-mail.
Also ich würde sagen es ist personenbezogen weil es zu einem
in dieser merkmals kombination zu einem fingerabdruck von mir wird juristen würden aber sagen jedes einzelne datum davon ist nicht personenbezogen und deswegen ist auch die summe nicht personenbezogen.
Nimmt aber dann gerne andere beispiele zum beispiel dein handy lockt sich in ein sozusagen der teller ein,
das dann auch personen bezogen oder ist das nur.
Mein handy ja.
Also sie versuchen die beispiele durch so zu wählen das sind immer weniger personen beziehbar wird also man muss schon die wehen die schon praktisch aus und du hast jetzt eins aussehen wird was so in der mitte ist und du kannst natürlich auch stärkere wählen wurde klar ist dass es personenbezogen ist,
die beispielsweise sagen die das ist nicht das würden wir auch gar nicht ausfiltern wenn wenn sich ein handy nur einloggt in die zelle also wie du beispiel willst,
kannst du natürlich auch sagen gerne filtern wir raus damit er mir nicht raus,
bin wie du sie willst macht dadurch auch einen gewissen eindruck auf die richter aber klar ist glaube ich jedem technik.
Sie versuchen.
Nimmt zu dass du immer mehr getriggert ereignisse hast also die jetzt die du nicht unbedingt wesentlich auslöst,
vor allen dingen mit mobiltelefon also glaube ich noch stärker als beim rechner und ja die fragen da da ist man.
Und das ist eben also der der punkt von dem ein bisschen angekommen sind ist genau diese unwissentlich getriggert ereignisse oder die die auch für den für die nutzerin nicht mehr kontrollierbar ereignisse
die dann auch viel mehr als jetzt kommunikation sind,
na das ist jetzt nicht mehr hier terrorist ein schreibt eine e-mail ein terrorist zwei sondern das ist,
eine eine erfassung von lebensbereichen von denen viele menschen vielleicht gar nicht wissen dass sie überhaupt lebensbereiche sind geschweige denn dass sie erfasst werden.
Und die man auch ziemlich gut automatisiert verarbeiten kann sollte man ja technisch auch mal so rum sehen also diese gerade diese maschine maschine kommunikation erlaubt ist natürlich ein analysten sehr viel einfacher solche profile zu erstellen weil die immer gleichartig sind.
Aber für manche dieser beispiel je nachdem wird jetzt konstruieren würdest musst du natürlich erst reinsehen in die kommunikation um zum beispiel erfolgreich herauszufiltern dass es in deutschland,
wenn du zum beispiel die sprache auch kennst oder so also,
da können wir jetzt wirklich viel konstruieren ich glaube aber einfach dass in diesem fall gar nicht so mit der knackpunkt war denn nicht mal der bmw sagt wir können es ganz toll hundert prozent was sie aber sagen wir.
Setzen menschen da hin also sie haben soweit wie sie können hundertfünfzigtausend meldungen sozusagen reduzieren per hand,
auf zweihundertsechzig am tag oder so also sie sie sagen wir haben einfach menschen und die sind erfahren dazu er ja dann haben wir da wirklich vorgebracht und sie haben interessanterweise dabei diese fremdsprachige zeit oft aussehen lassen man muss sich natürlich sagen wir reden im ausland,
und diese menschen die das sortieren die müssen dann natürlich dann auch,
die sprache inwieweit sprechen da geht es ja nicht immer nur deutsch war die richter haben da auch sehr viel.
Oder vor allen dingen die eine richterin hat er deutlich gemacht dass sie nicht verstehen kann wie diese riesenhafte sechsstellige anzahl reduziert wird auf ein paar hundert wie machen die das also der argumentiert einfach ja ja automatisch wäre da sagen wir gar nicht wir schaffen.
Machen wir mit algorithmus machen wir das.
Wir machen den mit menschen manuel.
War aber auch eine vertreterin des bnd da die hat erklärt wie diese magie in zukunft mit künstlicher intelligenz und mustererkennung.
Sagen das wird ja nicht.
Ja aber das ist doch nicht in betrieb.
Eine frage die ich stellen würde wäre was kostet euch diese filterung im jahr und daran könnte man ja eigentlich also da werde ich nämlich vermuten dass sie da wahrscheinlich nicht besonders viel geld für ausgeben.
Der bmw ist eine sehr große behörde der hat einen unglaublichen finanziellen und personellen aufwuchs ich glaube das nicht das problem.
Eben also.
Können menschen einsetzen.
Aber dass sie also das eine diese filter aufgabe,
war sie weil sie ja garantiert nicht perfekt laufen kann kannst du eigentlich so viel ressourcen drauf werfen wie du willst,
du willst immer noch fehler haben im zweifelsfall und dann wäre ja interessant zu sehen einfach nur an dem budget was ihr dafür haben wie ernst die diese filterung überhaupt nehmen.
Sie sagen unsere manuellen zu sagen oder die geheimnis mitarbeiter die manuell machen haben halt viel erfahrung denn die müssen ja nicht nur die deutschen weg filtern und so und dann sollen sie finden ja zum beispiel auch kernbereich relevante inhalte,
wurde mehr gefragt als deutsche also die frage
findet ein gespräch ist mit einem geistlichen oder gespräch mit einem engen partner im kind irgendwann über sex das müssen die ja auch aussortieren auch das haben sie natürlich nicht gut darlegen können weil wenn du so eine große menge hast
sie behaupten der zu sagen sie können halt ganz stark reduzieren dann und in der fremdsprache wie wie weißt du denn dass du da zu sagen gerade um religiöse sachverhalte geht oder so,
oder um sechs es ist ja nicht so einfach und denn wenn du über transkribiert und übersetzt wäre der neuerliche eingriff,
also da gibt's mehr oder wurde auch nicht immer so genau darauf eingegangen aber sie müssen ja mehr filtern als nur die deutschen raus.
Interessiert er eigentlich noch jemand wenn sie jetzt sagen wir filtern das mit menschen oder maschinen das ist ja auch so eine alte debatte das
ich glaube das waren aber eher in den amerikanischen debatten so ja das wird automatisch von maschinen gefiltert und das dann gesagt wurde ja und genau deshalb,
weil es von maschinen gefiltert wird ist es quasi nie erfasst worden,
wenn ich jetzt aber mir vorstelle meine kernbereich relevanten sexual geheimnisse werden von irgendwelchen männchen beim bnd,
mitgehört und dann entsprechend gefiltert dann will ich jetzt auch nicht sagen ach super super dass ich da abgehört wurde irgendein,
irgendjemand der ein multi sprachtalent hat jetzt festgestellt was ich da besprochen habe hat und hat das dann dann würde ich ja sagen das ist doch,
letztendlich die schwerste der schwerste eingriff den menschen sich überhaupt vorstellen können ist nun mal dass jemand anderes eben gerade mit hört,
und da interessiert sie ja wahrscheinlich skurrilerweise eher dass ein individuum mit hört das auch mensch ist als das eine maschine mit hört die maschine ist,
habe ich habe ich den eindruck.
Naja naja ich glaube ich weiß nicht wie das geht aber mir geht es immer so,
mein eindruck ist dass dieser kernbereich der privaten lebensgestaltung,
immer weniger verstanden wird also diese vermischung mit privatsphäre ist ganz stark leute vergessen glaube ich dass es ein absolut geschützter bereich ist unabhängig von der
der frage es sind jetzt noch eine maschine die rauf guckt ich glaube das verwischt sich einfach geht aber auch in gewisser weise technisch nicht anders weil wenn du eine massenüberwachung machst.
Da kannst du natürlich auch erstmal nicht verhindern dass in dieser masse auch höchstpersönlich drin ist die frage ist wie du damit umgehst im im
im kleinen bereich also wie bei der diskussion die großen lausche eingriff da mussten sie eine prognose machen sie müssen sagen wenn ihr keine wand so hin mache es wird wahrscheinlich dass die höchstpersönliches besprechen,
und es geht aber natürlich nicht bei einer massenüberwachung wie witzig machen du musst aber natürlich verhindern dass die diese.
Irgendwie eingriffe in diesem kernbereich die passieren aufgenommen werden du musst dir sofort löschen das ist jetzt ein ziel das ist aber eine eigene stufe niedriger als früher früher ging die diskussion darum ob in,
irgendwie verhindern kann dass diese absolut geschützten bereich betreten wird
und das kannst du ja nicht wenn du ein rohdaten strom hast da werden immer auch telefon gespräche oder gespräche mit psychologen oder so oder fotos von der geburt der kinder dabei sein also höchstpersönliches,
die jetzt diese spezielle frage die du ansprichst ist ja nur eine maschine wurde hier nicht interessiert das hatte ich bei mir,
bei menschenrechtsrat wurdet mal kurz angesprochen so sind sie hier aber gar nicht zu diesem thema gekommen.
Ich finde das nur als phänomen halt interessant weil also ich denke da zum beispiel an diese debatten um diese home assistenten alexa und wann nicht alles ne das
jeder weiß die dinger du redest da mit irgendeiner cloud aber es war ein völliger also alle waren in
wilder aufruhr als es hieß zur qualitätssicherung hören menschen sich die dinger an die irgendwie schief gegangen sind oder so oder wat
da ist ein mensch am anderen ende so während ja eigentlich die die vorstellung die einen,
mehr beunruhigen sollte ist dass da irgendwie eine maschine mit einer sehr viel höheren verarbeitung kapazität als ein mensch von millionen anschlüssen sekündlich diese aufzeichnung bekommt,
diese das interessiert mich wie.
Es ist hier nicht wirklich besprochen worden aber ich denke mal das ist emotional menschliches oder dass leute dieses gefühl da ist jemand der hört meinen.
Meine intimsten gedanken schlimmer findet als eine maschine verarbeitet ich denke das ist irgendwie sehr menschliche dümmste jeder psychologe.
Ich blicke da seit längerem interessiert drauf weil zum beispiel als diese ganze snowden geschichte losging.
Und es da mal irgendwie die sprache ich glaube da kam zu sprache wieviel terabyte oder peter bald die einspeichern kapazität hat und dann hat er michael krall war das glaube ich damals diese grafik gemacht wo er gesagt hat hier pass mal auf
das sind die aktenordner meter auf quadratmeter gerechnet die die stasi jemals überhaupt hingekriegt hat und hier neben,
rechnen wir jetzt mal diese peter beides um in,
ausgedruckte dina vier seiten und damalig jetzt mal hin so wir bräuchten lager von was weiß ich das hat aber irgendwie größer als berlin oder sich also die die datenmengen waren gar nicht mehr vergleichbar,
so und über die die die die stasi finden alle ganz fürchterlich und diese.
Vollautomatisierte datenerfassung nicht obwohl sie die viel viel viel krassere.
Macht kontrolle verarbeitung erfassung feingliedrig zeiten
erlaubt ja es geht nicht nur um geheimdienste geht auch umso so scherze wie cambridge analytica und überhaupt
werbung auf facebook was ja schon grundsätzlich zeigt wo dieses macht potenzial halt mal entfaltet wird und
ich finde es erstaunlich dass das dass das das menschliche wahrnehmen dieser bedrohung das emotionale wahrnehmen dieser eingriffe,
nicht dem.
Sag mal mit dem gesellschaftlichen bedrohungslage potenzial entspricht und deswegen hätte ich gedacht dass das aus irgendwelchen also dass das vielleicht in so einem verfahren auch eine eine form von berücksichtigung findet.
Haben das einfach erschlagen mit dem argument dass das menschen aussortieren dazu sind wir nicht mehr kommen auch weil die der der aspekt der massenüberwachung stand nicht so sehr im fokus,
wenn man jetzt die gesamten stunden sieht ich will aber nochmal hinzufügen zu dem was du gesagt hast drei beispiele hängt natürlich ein bisschen ja weil einfach man muss man muss so kenntnis nehmen.
Erst mit der digitalisierung so ist dass wir unser höchstpersönliches digital vermitteln das hätten wir früher nicht können und haben noch nicht getan aber der punkt ist dran.
Und die stasi hatte in sorry noch da hat er wurde natürlich sowieso nur das dann aufs papier geschrieben was der über wacher irgendwie jetzt meinte dahin schreiben zu müssen.
Aber die kann auch schon mal höchstpersönlich sein wenn.
Natürlich natürlich natürlich aber da wurde jetzt zum beispiel wenig,
ja gut ist auch unsinn der aber die haben wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze menge irrelevant ist in die akten geschrieben hab damit so wenigstens geliefert haben über irgendwelche langweiler die sie jetzt irgendwie bespitzeln mussten oder so ne aber das waren
verarbeitete daten im vergleich zu oder vielleicht das ist.
Ich will einen punkt nennt ihr dazu noch drauf kommt das könnte man für deinen facebook natürlich auch machen man muss sich klarmachen versucht auch in karlsruhe zu sagen
die macht hat noch einen anderen aspekt nämlich dass man schöpft aus dieser menge also,
einer der bnd leute hat dafür einen wunderbaren begriff gefunden nämlich die generieren bestellzettel,
also das ist ja nicht nur dass du du findest neue anhaltspunkte um weiter zu überwachen in dieser masse siehste,
also ich glaube diese potenzial kann man auch für chemisch analytiker sagen wird oft nicht so richtig dabei mit
bedacht dass du ja weitere anfasser findest sozusagen wo du dich weiter hangeln kannst du nutzt ja diese menge diesen heuhaufen auch um interessante sektoren und suchbegriffe also war die der hattet bestellt sein genannt.
Du gehst quasi explorativ dadurch und sagst was haben wir denn hier.
Du findest auch neue ansätze um weiter zu zu zu suchen das ist natürlich also so wie so kann man auch mit diesen hops kommen ne
so kommst du von einer person zur nächsten du merkst dir mit wem kommuniziert jemand da ist ja die mächtigkeit besteht auch in dem potenzial watt die analyse dieses riesen blockst,
hier gibt es mehrere seiten.
Und das wiederum macht zwar eigentlich interessanter der sagen wir geben teile dieses blogs weiter.
Hat sie auch gemacht haben in der vergangenheit.
Ohne ohne zu ohne eigentlich den wert zu kennen also man was man da noch so alles raus meinen.
Na ja wir wissen ja also
einige darüber zu sagen über diesen ausschuss wir wissen ja einige aber es geht ja auch nochmal um noch was anderes nochmal einen drauf setzen nämlich die potenz des gesetzes wir reden ja über ein gesetz verfassungswidrig ist und die frage ist ja auch nicht
was können sie heute technisch sondern die frage ist natürlich auch was können sie übermorgen wie viel dürfen sie denn mit diesem gesetz abhören und verarbeiten.
Und das hat die richter auch interessiert also weil ich weiß dass es zum beispiel bei dem,
staatstrojaner ich kenne ja deine stellungnahme wo du,
da auch sehr spezifisch drauf eingegangen bis das hat sich vor zehn jahren fast so ein bisschen esoterisch gelesen
ja also wenn man nicht vor zehn jahren da gab's gerade ein iphone und da hast du ja schon
geschrieben so da werden sich hier das was kernbereich ist das was intimität ist das wird alles sich darin abbilden wir haben noch ein paar jahre dann haben wir einfach alle weitere computer und das,
ich sag mal zu dem zeitpunkt hätte ich mir vorstellen können das wahrscheinlich der ein oder andere auch gesagt hat hör mal schreibt man science-fiction roman,
und lass mal hier das gericht in ruhe wenige jahre später hatte sich das alles sehr bewahrheitet was was was du da ausgeführt hast.
Die bundesregierung hat ein argument dagegen ich wäre es nicht immer nur unsere seite hier mal darstellen die bundesregierung sagt naja der gesetzgeber kann nacharbeiten wenn sie sozusagen die fähigkeiten die technischen diäten.
Macht er ja gerade deswegen steht ihr hier gerade vom verfassungsgericht wir wir arbeiten ne die sollen ja auch zu wort kommen der gesetzgeber kann nacharbeit.
Das war schon das argument also.
Achso okay haben wir jetzt.
Ich wollte nur mal sagen wie sagen natürlich die hören dieses argument nicht so gerne dass man über die potenz des gesetzes so redet der wird natürlich haben die richter das selber getriggert indem wir zum beispiel wissen wollten was bedeutet dann praktisch in,
volumina also wieviel der globalen kombination der globalen verkehre kann man denn damit will also die haben uns selber so ein bisschen getriggert,
wir wissen.
Gut dass du den punkt ansprichst spielen dabei auch diese wieviel überhaupt prozent erfasst werden darf das muss doch eine lange diskussion gewesen sein oder auch nicht.
Es wurde natürlich schon teilweise schriftlich also wir haben dazu was geschrieben aber vor allen dingen hat er gut dazu eine länge schreiben können es gibt natürlich keine,
du kannst jetzt nicht sagen siebenunddreißig prozent also so so nicht aber du kannst natürlich irgendwie so ein bisschen die die volumina hinschreiben in deutschland,
es ist in gewisser weise man kann sagen es ist ein gewisser standortvorteil a dass wir in der mitte von continental europa sind aber auch dass wir bestimmte ökonomische und vertragliche anreize haben wir haben ziemlich viel peeling,
bei uns also und wir haben aber auch nach relativ freie zone ist tatsächlich ein standortvorteil,
wenn du hier als großer anbieter pierce dann gehst du nicht davon aus dass dein rohdaten strom ausgeweitet wird wird also.
Es ist ein standortvorteil also,
wir müssen mal sehen mit diesen zahlen werden sie letztendlich so sehr viel anfangen es liegt
an einer wie man das argument dafür nennen das liegt an der letzten entscheidung über das gesetz von hundertneunundneunzig da haben sie nämlich deswegen noch als verhältnismäßig
erkannt weil sie gesagt haben ist so ein kleiner
kleiner anteil den sie technisch wirklich erfassen können und so hat er mir die jetzt auch argumentiert hat gesagt es ist so ein geringer anteil den wir,
erfassen das hat eigentlich gar nicht wirklich der rede wert ist.
Und das ist halt das ist natürlich ein sehr
unsauberes argument weil der größere teil des dessen was menschen an internetverkehr produzieren,
im zweifelsfall nicht in die verarbeitung muss die also so ein so ein mensch guckt dann irgendwie ein youtube video da wäre das ist dann von mir aus sauer zweihundert vierzig jetzt muss natürlich nicht erfasst werden dass der,
dass er
dass der vierzig übertragen wurden die vierzig irgendwo gespeichert wurden sondern es reicht im prinzip aha zugriff auf das video was dort ist das video wird dort bleiben und hat folgenden titel das heißt sie ist das datenvolumen was der übertragen wurde von von mir aus jetzt vierzig
lässt sich speichern reduzieren auf wenige beide oder kilobyte ja.
Ne wir wissen ja zum beispiel von den sehr viel größeren operationen temporär also die briten die haben ja zu dem temporär programm ist ja ein ein wichtiger bestandteil die volumen reduzierung
meißen youtube und youporn da scheint sie weg und dann machen die automatisiert sie müssen weil sie sonst sehr überlaufen,
bei dem wissen wir auch da gibt's eine volumen reduktion wir wissen nur nicht so viel darüber wie er aus den sound papieren aber das wird so ähnlich laufen.
Und dann ist aber jede jede prozent angabe verliert ihren sinn.
Ich denke die verliert nicht ihren sinn weil weil die richter ja wissen wollen wie viel,
können sie mit diesem gesetz haben willst du das ist ja eine andere frage als wie viel müssen die wegschmeißen,
das ist ja so ein bisschen können die können sie mit diesem wenn sie bei uns sozusagen ihre daten schnorchler ransetzen an die exchanges wieviel kriegen ihn dann von weltweiter kommunikation das ist ja so ein bisschen die frage bist du.
Warte also ich würde ja okay vielleicht kannst du mir sagen wo man denkfehler ist nehmen wir an aus irgendwelchen gründen wäre diese zwanzig prozent regelung irgendwie jetzt.
Gott gegeben man würde sagen ihr dürft jetzt zwanzig prozent des internetverkehrs dürft ihr ja und jetzt lebt leben wir in einer welt in der man hingeht und sagt,
fünfundachtzig prozent des internetverkehrs sind youtube und netflix ja so dass klar ist wenn man den gesamten weltweiten internetverkehr nimmt,
dann kann man alles was nicht was alles was nicht videostreaming macht gerade mal fünfzehn prozent aus das heißt wir hätten noch luft nach oben.
Aber also den ist doch letztlich egal wie viel du wegschmeißen wenn du von rohdaten strömen redest du,
tu dir der inhalt erstmal nicht zur sache sondern du sagst dir wie viel prozent von pro daten können die haben wie viel die wegschmeißen ist ja der zweite schritt ist und deshalb nur also ja das ist natürlich eine relevante frage aber wenn du jetzt erstmal trichter nur wissen willst,
was können die denn potenziell haben sozusagen von einem globalen verkehr dann interessiert dich ja nicht.
Achso dann interessiert mich wo deine tabs sind und dann hast du sagst es eben hier in frankfurt und da der größere teil also immer noch der internet ist immer noch sehr viel größer als der in frankfurt und dann gibt's halt relativ viel wo wir gar nicht drankommen.
Aber wie viel läuft auch über die großen continental europäischen knoten wie ebene deko,
wir haben ja mehr aber ich glaube wir haben sechzehn exchanges in deutschland also unterschiedlicher größe oder so zwölf oder sechzehn oder sowas dann wurde da auch mal erzählt aber ich habe jetzt gerade meine papiere nicht bei so weil man muss ja mal das papier aufschreiben,
tatsächlich wissen wir natürlich jetzt praktisch eine ganze menge und wie der bnd abhört schlicht weil diese verhandlungen vom bundesverwaltungsgericht gibt
aber die hat ja auch interessiert durch die struktur der paket vermittelten kommunikation wieviel ist denn das praktisch und die hat's natürlich auch vor allen dingen für auslands ausland kommunikation interessiert.
Und werde okay weil okay die wollen darauf hinaus dass sie sagen okay wenn wenn da sowieso nicht so viel auslands auslands kommunikation an dem deko ist was okay verstehe.
Es ist übrigens das würde ich auch nochmal dazu sagen wir reden nicht immer nur über fiber also glasfaserkabel sondern natürlich auch über satelliten,
bus da wartet halt wenig da war wenig zu darüber zu sagen aber auch darüber müssen sie natürlich sprechen.
Also weil wir immer wir haben irgendwie immer diese exchanges ja theoretisch in dem gesetz steht sehr viel mehr du konntest natürlich zum beispiel auch zu ackern mailen und sagen bitte hier einmal,
die definition wo die ran dürfen es größer wir wissen halt nur wegen des anderen verfahren ist eine menge darüber was die praktisch tun dann finden sie natürlich auch nicht gut
ich denke der wird nicht sehr begeistert gewesen sein wie genau über diese anordnung und über die auch
richtig praktische ausleitung mit so einem noch ein stück und dass sie eben rohdaten kriegen jetzt die öffentlichkeit weiß da sind sie sicherlich nicht beeindruckt darüber natürlich alles soweit,
er als geheimen einstufen.
Was würdest du denn noch an an,
an highlights aus dieser aus dieser diskussion sehen also ich denke haben wir jetzt überhaupt erst mal die,
position der beschwerdeführer drin und der sachverständigen auf der sagen wir mal grundrecht freundlichen seite vollständig gewürdigt.
Nein haben wir nicht matthias becker als,
wer ist ein juraprofessor der sozusagen der zentrale sprecher dort als voll möchte der hat einfach sehr gute stellungnahmen schon vorher
abgegeben ein teil davon ist auch öffentlich der hat im wesentlichen mit dem fernmeldegeheimnis und der pressefreiheit argumentiert also der der sagt ich habe hier berufsgesetz träger journalisten die gehören geschützt,
man kann nicht einfach den bmw bmw erlauben dass er da diese informanten und journalisten und deren redaktionelle netzwerke ja
dass er da rein schnorcheln der hat wirklich gute argumente gemacht auch warum fernmeldegeheimnis eben,
nicht nur für deutsche gilt sondern
ein grundrecht ist was auch andere schützt der hat aber zu allen diesen punkten die wir jetzt erwähnt haben natürlich schon vorher plädiert aber christian mir von reporter ohne grenzen hatte auch selber gesprochen die beschwerdeführer dürfen sich ja auch äußern hat nochmal sein fall,
geschildert also was sind das für menschen und warum sind die gefährdet durch den geheimdienst der sie abhört ja der hat seinen seinen seinen sind so drei seiten oder so,
schriftlich die hatte auch online gestellt bei reporter ohne grenzen das fand ich sehr schön dass er sich da selber auch nochmal zu wort gemeldet hat sollte man glaube ich jetzt auch nicht ja
sollte man nicht vergessen dass die einfach versuchen strukturell journalisten zu schützen und die pressefreiheit hochzuhalten neben dem fernmeldegeheimnis.
Und also fällt das auf fruchtbaren boden da.
Ja natürlich wär's ein verfassungsgericht ja die haben natürlich die grundrechte finden die schon wichtig und die fragen waren auch sehr kritisch
die haben da schon teilweise vor allen dingen den vertreter der bundesregierung den wlan den ja schon mal erwähnt der politische grillt die haben immer wieder nachgefragt vor allen dingen wenn er auch nicht die antwort hat die frage richtig nochmal gestellt,
mit war schon so der hat sich auch so ein bisschen verheddert und immer wieder nur gesagt alle ausländer kriegen grundrechte was natürlich auch also gar nicht.
Gar nicht so auf der intellektuellen flughöhe ist die der normalerweise kommt muss man so sagen ja im.
Ich denke dass der das aber wirklich strategischen gründen getan hat in der wollte dass diese diese message,
alle ausländer kriegen grundrechte der presse landet auf meiner sicht aber gar nicht geschehen also die fdp getickert hat war durchaus ein bisschen,
weniger platt fand ich gut das ist also nicht so durchgedrungen ist ich glaube auch nicht wenn die eine anhörung machen dass man,
mit dem argument überhaupt noch durchkommt dass dass man darüber gar nicht reden kann dass diese journalisten die dort beschwerdeführer sind hier nicht gar nicht zulässige weise beschwerdeführer sind ich glaube da kommt man nicht mehr durch.
Ich wäre das nicht ohnehin also die entscheidung auf die beschwerde zulässig ist die hätte das gericht auch schon längst gefällt.
Also ein zentraler teil der bundesregierung zur argumentation auch schriftlich schon vorher.
Ist das ein pferd auf das die setzen können ne ne.
Nein nein nein aus meiner sicht überhaupt nicht aber.
Also wenn das gericht schon direkt zwei tage anberaumt ja wäre es ja schon jetzt erstaunlich wenn die dann sagen hör mal hier weiter gesagt recht es ist überhaupt nicht unsere abteilung hier.
Du musst dir einfach vorstellen am anfang sind da sehr viele pressevertreter noch und die wollten dieses argument machen immer wieder hat er gesagt alle ausländer kriegen jetzt die ganze welt kriegt hier grundrechte das hat er immer wieder
wiederholt und außerdem hat er natürlich am anfang gesagt die kontrolle ist super
wie unsere väter sind fantastisch ja du musst dir mal vorstellen dass die die so argument hin als wenn der janosch anders macht als bloß die grundrechtsträger natürlich,
zu schützen das ist die zentrale aufgabe ja die geben sich so mühe den kernbereich zu schützen und die filtern die schwitzen alle beim filtern,
natürlich die andere position die haben sie auch dargelegt oder auch also der,
der präsident hat sich's auch nicht nehmen lassen gleich am anfang zu sprechen wir sammeln nachrichten wir schützen die bundeswehr ist dann wird natürlich die gegenposition auch total aufgemacht
die haben die reden und nicht von überwachung sondern immer ist aufklärung und so.
Finde ich ja auf einen gewissen rahmen auch vollkommen legitim ja dass sie ihre ihr selbstverständnis und ihre aufgaben da im besten licht darstellen ist ja zu erwarten sind ja.
Sie sind das auge und rohr der bundesregierung sie machen ja weil die bundesregierung sagt im auftakt vor viel und sie bieten dann relevante informationen aus diesen aus dieser strategischen fernwert aufklärung.
Tun sie ja
also natürlich relevant wird das nicht sein was sie da machen also dafür dafür würde die bundesregierung dann schon im zweifelsfall sagen hör mal ich will hier mehr mehr an an meinem
an meinen knochen haben.
Die richter wollten das auch mal wissen also die haben wir zwar schon mal gefragt wie abstrakt ist dann dein auftragsprozesse steht da drin
also wie oder ist das schon personenbezogen und dann die antworten sind dann so da präsent ihr sagt na ja also teilweise abstrakt teilweise konkret die machen da kein beispiel ist.
Erstaunlich.
Sie hatten nur ein problem was immer wieder erwähnt wurde das halt ein teil überhaupt nicht im ist jetzt hier regelt ist sondern dass sie nach der verfassungsbeschwerde eine art sind dienstanweisung gegeben haben also,
dienstvorschrift dick so heißt die dies hat nicht teil des gesetzes,
aber darauf haben die sehr viel abgestellt also man sagt da steht wir haben eine dienstvorschrift und deswegen,
gucken wir immer nach deutschen und kernbereich.
Das interessiert doch dass das interessiert das bundesverfassungsgericht nicht oder die urteilen doch über gesetze oder nicht oder beziehungsweise über gesetz verstöße.
Haben sie damit begründet wie wie sehr sie im vorauseilendem gehorsam sozusagen auf die grundrechte achten das ist aber auch das habe ich auch schon in anderen verfahren bei geheimdiensten erlebt dass sie oft auf solche dienstanweisungen abstellen.
Schön dass unser land mit dienstanweisungen.
Mir lag die auch nicht vor die richter hatten die aber also diese dienstanweisungen über die auch mehrfach konkret gesprochen wurde die hatten die offenbar also wer da wurde auch mal drüber gesprochen konkret was da drin steht.
So da waren wir jetzt schon eigentlich am zweiten tag.
Der erste war sozusagen dieser ganze block zulässigkeit zitiere geburt also ein bisschen die formalien und dann die datenerhebung und am zweiten tag,
war dann so einen übergang zu,
kontrolle datenweitergabe also man die wollten das eigentlich schaffen an einem tag haben sie aber nicht war nicht möglich einfach von der fülle,
und weil eben diese eine gutachter dieser brite wegmusste haben sie teil des kontrollbereich nämlich zum beispiel zu haben aus einem anderen land noch an den ersten tag gezogen wird eigentlich später in der tagesordnung war.
Beispiel was im anderen land finde ich tatsächlich eine spannende spannende.
Ich habe mich damit sehr schwer getan weil es eben ich bin einer der beschwerdeführer gegen.
Gegen genau das was der.
Fremde strategisch warte glaube ich sehr klug,
einfach zu sehen selbst die briten haben das besser hingekriegt aber für mich war die position die dir da eingenommen hat viel zu unkritisch ja.
Wenn man da hört wird unsere anwälte in straßburg argumentiert haben da war der weit fort entfernt andererseits war das natürlich in gewisser weise klug einfach nur zu sagen wie ist denn aus sicht der kontrollbehörde jetzt geschaffen,
leider muss man natürlich auch zusagen und relativ neu ist also richtig viel praktische erfahrung haben die natürlich noch nicht.
Wie ist das denn dann also dann jetzt endet der erste tag
wenn ich mal also ist das kann man da mal so so jetzt der erste tag sei es müssen all die köpfe rauchen irgendwie neun stunden da gesessen hoch hoch konzentriert man versucht man bildet ja wahrscheinlich auch die ganze zeit irgendwelche prothesen darüber.
Was denkt er was ich denke was ich weiß was er denkt was.
Da gibt es aber auch die pausen noch da wird er auch schon ganz viel miteinander geredet wird.
Es gibt pausen ja.
Es gibt eine längere und ganz wenig also wir hatten eine mittagspause und dann nochmal eine zehn minuten pause war wirklich echt wenig pausen etwa also ich konnte sehr sehr anstrengend ich denke weil die einfach versucht hat oder vielleicht haben,
die richter eine weile lang noch angenommen sie schaffen es an einem tag,
deswegen also ich fand das extrem anstrengend aber in den pausen wird natürlich auch schon orakelt und so interpretiert und abgesprochen und es ist so,
und dann zwischen den tagen gibt's natürlich auch wer ist mit wem wer redet mit wem man muss sich unbedingt austauschen und so ja ja klar das ist eben so ein bisschen aufregung ist da auch.
Gibt's vermischung der beiden teams.
Also bei mir nee wenn wir nicht aufgefallen dass also da ist jetzt nicht die beschwerdeführer mit dem bmw.
Es ist nur einer von b n ist bei euch.
Naja wir hatten bei den sachverständigen war er unter anderem der herr schall bruch dabei der ist ja früher war ja früher im innenministerium.
Ja der martin schalke.
Ja genau also man müsste es jetzt nicht so krass also dass man oder zum beispiel auf der seite der bundesregierung sagt ja auch noch der konstantin von notz der ist ja,
opposition weil er zum parlamentarischen kontrollgremium gehört also das ist jetzt nicht immer so klar getrennt und man steht auch mal in den pausen beieinander weil man sich vielleicht kennt oder so willst du kommt schon mal.
Wäre jetzt
eigentlich wenn man die rolle von konstantin von notz als innenpolitiker der grünen in politischer sprecher der grünen glaube ich sehr sehr vielen jahren seine rolle im untersuchungsausschuss
und seine sonstigen politischen positionen berücksichtigt könnte man fast denken dass der wahrscheinlich eher.
Man muss sehen die kennt sich halt teilweise von notz ist ja zum beispiel einer der parlamentarier der an dem bmw fragen gestellt hat sowohl im untersuchungsausschuss wie ein pkw also das ich glaube nicht dass es also man man kriegt ja nicht die krätze ja nur weil man zusammen ist aber,
ich glaube das handhaben leute unterschiedlich also hier wird niveau seit
eigentlich auch so dass du sachlich bleiben willst blieb auch immer sachlich zwar hat aus meiner sicht zumindest der vertreter der bundesregierung der wieland,
teilweise ein bisschen unredlich wie er diese zulässigkeit frage geklärt hatte einfach weil er diese den asyl asylgrundrecht mit reingenommen das war sicherlich ein bisschen überzogen aber sitzt,
sehr sachlich.
Voll geblieben kann er vortragen wenn er wenn er seine zeit dafür verwenden möchte steht es ihm ja frei zu sagen was aber du du willst also sagen er hat es er hat es sachlich und sittsam getan auch wenn es unredlich war.
Ja also also das ist jetzt wirklich kann überhaupt nicht sagen dass es im großteil ist das auch nicht irgendwie polemisch oder so sondern also da werden schon argumente vorgetragen und ein bisschen.
Na mit wem warst du denn abends essen jetzt sag.
Da ist es schon so dass die sachverständige noch oft unter sich bleiben also einfach weil ach gott du redest natürlich auch ganz gerne ein bisschen mit jemand den du kennst oder so ja
jetzt hat sie war natürlich auch leute vom c karlsruhe noch da da sind auch leute im publikum die du kennst ja so
ich würde mich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt zum bmw begeben wollen ich glaube aber das ist.
Die ich weiß gar nicht ob die nach reisekosten richtig in die überhaupt ordentlich essen können da müssen die nicht müssen die nicht dann irgendwie also ich weiß es nicht ich stelle mir das auf jeden fall nicht nicht nicht angenehm vor.
Na ja weiß ich nicht also.
Die dürfen ja beim essen eh nicht reden.
Na ja ich weiß nicht ob so eine so eine höheren beamten vom bmw ich denke mal die werden,
wir haben ja auch ihre person schwitzer mit und so ich weiß nicht genau wie sie ob die ob die noch so ein leben führen dass sie einfach in irgendeiner karlsruhe kneipe gehen und sich dann stärkeren pfeifen oder ich weiß es nicht ich habe keine ahnung.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Keine ahnung vielleicht werden sie auch abtransportiert in ihren limousinen ich weiß es nicht ich hab's auch nicht beobachtet weil wir eine weile stehen bleiben dann nochmal kurz uns ausgetauscht haben und dann waren die da schon weg.
Okay und dann geht man also in einer in einer runde essen du hast jetzt auch schon gesagt okay die sachverständige es ist schon so dass es sachverständigen also es gibt sachverständige der einen seite und sachverständige der anderen seite.
Die sachverstand sind erstmal alle vom gericht benannt.
Sind die genau interessanter punkt so jetzt.
Die laden ein ein nicht alle tun das nicht alle haben eine stellungnahme abgegeben du wirst ja angeschrieben.
Geladen als vertreterin des c hast eine stellungnahme eingereicht und dann glaube ich danach eine ladung heute auch sein können dass du keine kriegst dass sie sagen nee danke oder.
Ich denke die laden alle die sie als sachverständiger benennen.
Wie viele waren das denn.
Wie gesagt das war herr schreibbuch,
der jetzt in die akademie gewechselt aber da war früher im innenministerium und dann war dieser britische hitman hieß der der sozusagen als vertreter des commission dass also als dann kontrollbehörde da war dann war noch klaus landesvater würde ich mir schon erwähnt haben vom echo
und dann war noch ein vertreter da der telekom herr ennolat,
ich denke schon ich weiß nicht genau hat nur so ganz sehr sehr kurze stellungnahme abgegeben war mir nicht ganz klar weswegen aber dann gibt's auch noch sachverständige die aufgrund ihres amtes da sind also jetzt,
also ich war auch da zum beispiel kälber
als bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte aber dann war auch noch eine sehr interessant sprechende richterin da die das neue unabhängige kontrollgremium repräsentiert hat konstantin von notz war zum beispiel da der ja auch wieder ein vertreter des parlamentarischen kontrollgremium ist der vorsitzende war da der herr schuster
die sind ja in ihrem amt da die die gehört dazu.
Also schon eine große menge leute ich würde sagen war bestimmt vierzig mann da auf den bänken verteilt also in dreier-reihen denke schon ja.
Die alle sachverständige achso.
Interessant wenn jetzt alle anwälte und dann auch ein paar von den vertretern die jetzt namentlich am anfang nicht vorgestellt worden aber später zum beispiel zur technischen aufklärung von b n gehört haben.
Primär wort führend gestaltend wirken dann matthias becker.
Der vertreter der bundesregierung wieland ja
weil die eben auch immer wieder zwischendurch argumente austauschen es gab da wieso interims argumente also bäcker hatte doch sehr sachlich gemacht und hat dann sozusagen nach ein paar stunden die verfassungsrechtlichen probleme die bisher aufgetaucht sind nochmal zusammengefasst das muss man dann auch adhock bringen,
er hat dabei aber natürlich auch argumente wiederholt die schriftlich schon mal gemacht hat er hat sie teilweise zugespitzt oder was betont oder so.
Und dann gibst du aber auch schon nochmal gerede und gegenrede,
der wieland hat jetzt so gemacht der hat eigentlich nur reagiert auf die wortmeldung von becker das kenne ich auch teilweise anders manche vertreter der bundesregierung haben eigene akzente gesetzt du siehst schon dass ich von dem wieder nicht so sehr begeistert war,
auch intellektuell nicht aus meiner sicht muss es sich mal ganz deutlich sagen,
in der frage der zulässigkeit und der frage wie weit grundrechte reichen hat er sich richtig auch von den verfassungsrichter belehren lassen müssen also,
das machen die auch sehr deutlich wenn sie argumente die jemand vorbringt seitens der bundesregierung für absolut verfehlt halten dann sagen die das auch.
Und wenn sie also ihm dreimal dieselbe frage stellt und er dann nicht anfordert ist schon so als wenn sie in berlin ist schon denke das hatte publikum auch bemerkt.
Das habe ich aber auch schon auch schon andere vertreter der bundesregierung die dort erlebt habe die sich sehr blamiert haben aber eben auch nicht alle,
manche bleiben so sagen auf einem gewissen niveau ich finde wie dann hatte nicht immer geschafft also wenn du mit so einem argumenten kommst immer wieder sagst alle ausländer kriegen jetzt grundrechte dann ist das nicht adäquat für die argumente die die die richter da geben oder auch.
Schon davon ausgehen dass du damit mit mit ernstzunehmenden leuten dich unterhälst ne.
Wenn du ein mageres oder ein nicht argument immer wieder integrierst blamierst du dich und dann geben sie dir auch zu verstehen.
Hallo.
Wenn eine richterin zu dir sagt also sie haben jetzt wieder die präambel,
erwähnt weil er ja die territorien territoriale angesprochen also der deutsche volk wie erklären sie sich denn dass da eben bestimmte grundrechte nur für deutsche gelten dann ist das natürlich schon irgendwie eine,
eine klatsche für ein juraprofessor man musste natürlich als.
So ein bisschen auf dem niveau einer mündlichen prüfung dann nochmal runter geht und sagte er verstehe ich aber jetzt gerade gar nicht was.
Also wenn du von der richter bank erklärt bekommen hast das wird abwehrrechte gibt oder eben leistungsrechte und dass man die anders betrachten muss und das oder wenn richter zu dir sagt verzeihung das sind deutsche behörde die vom inland ausländer ab,
abhört leute dann nicht diese betroffenen recht haben auch sozusagen ihre grundrechte geltend zu machen es wird schon ganz schön.
Hallo.
Also weil diese behörde kriegt ihr einen gesetzlichen auftrag und selbstverständlich also ich denke das ist auch in diesem
gericht sei jedem klar gewesen muss eine möglichkeit geben sich dagegen zu wehren auch für diejenigen die außerhalb von deutschland davon betroffen sind und das sind ja die beschwerdeführer das sind nun mal auch ausländische journalisten die eben
ja die sind eben die überwachungs- opfer und ich denke er hat politische argument machen wollen.
Wie glaubst du geht es jetzt weiter also.
Ein paar sachen sind ja klar das eine ist,
ein bisschen formal er der berichterstatter massing das ist ein letztes urteil dann hört er sozusagen beim gericht auf der wird das urteil schreiben das ist so üblich dass der berichterstattung tut dann wird es beraten und das dauert mehrere monate.
Ist das dann auch so wie am wie hier am eugh dass der general berichterstatter irgendwie ein vorschlag macht und dass da noch mal oder eine empfehlung macht und nee.
Dieses institut von dem generalanwalt den es gibt den gibt es so gar nicht
wir haben mit der interessanterweise gerade am letzten tag viel ja aufeinander der,
eugh generalanwalt dieses argument gegen die vorratsdatenspeicherung gemacht hat dass man nämlich auch
aus gründen der terrorismusabwehrzentrum keine anlasslose massenüberwachung aller machen darf es war genau der sozusagen zweite tag in der anhörung in karlsruhe aber diese dieses institut gibt es nicht nur am eugh,
und der berichterstatter wird auch kein wird auch nicht irgendwie öffentlich sondern ist eine interne gerichts beratung bis das urteil kommt es wird in mehreren monaten sein,
sich noch ein bisschen hinziehen.
Der arme herr martin wenn man den google da findet man dann noch irgendwie ohne seine rote robe als erstes bild das gibt's doch nicht.
Ist ja auch ein gestandener jurist der wird dann sicherlich auch nachher wieder als professor irgendwo arbeiten denke ich also.
Uni freiburg scheint er herzukommen.
Weiß ich nicht also der hat keinen sehr erkennbaren akzent manchmal dialekt manche richter haben wird wenn die reden dann weißt du die kommen aus dem süden oder aus dem norden aber bei ihm ich kann's nicht okay.
Geboren in wiesbaden seit april zwanzig acht richter des bundesverfassungsgerichts.
Ich habe den schon mal erlebt der war auch berichterstatter beim gesetz,
und hat da ja auch ein riesen langen gut mehrere hundert seiten gutachten geschrieben deswegen wird wird sich hier ein bisschen kleiner im rahmen bewegen weil nicht so viele rechtsfragen da sind aber natürlich ist die hoffnung dass
das urteil auch kritisch wird also ich habe auch keinen zweifel dass teile davon werden verfassungswidrig sein,
die frage ist welche und wie stark wird ganz sicherlich nicht das ganze gesetz in bausch und bogen verdammt werden das sicherlich nicht.
Ist ja leider so dass die bundesverfassungsrichterin urteile in den seltensten fällen ich meine vorratsdatenspeicherung war ja so einer wo gesagt wurde das ist jetzt voll vollständig ungültig das könnte vollständig vergessen.
Muss gelöscht werden vollständig vergessen also und sie mussten die daten sofort löschen und beim wahlcomputer war die auch so also diese vorschrift war verfassungswidrig ende der durchsage keine wahlcomputer ja das war aber beim ist es weit ganz anders.
Ja da war so ein so ein ja aber und irgendwie auf der siebten verästelungen des nebensatzes drei da müsst ihr noch mal jetzt nach ordnen dafür.
Antiterror datei war auch ganz anders,
also da war ja auch nur so teile und also sehr große abstufungen in den paragraphen um marvin ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt dass er,
der ist nicht so der typ mit einem hammer der ist eher der typ für etwas regelungen mal sehen.
Der arbeitet eher mit der pinzette als mit dem mit dem schweren gerät.
Zumindest mein eindruck weil beim gesetz wirklich ein ein sehr komplexes urteil war,
kann man nicht anders sagen mal sehen also die fragen sind durchaus kritische wesen aber martin hat er selbst gar nicht so sehr viel gefragt wann viele andere richter die gefragt haben.
Also es ist jetzt auch von der von den kritischen fragen,
abzuleiten auf das urteil ist natürlich auch echt ein weiterer schritt na.
Wieso.
Meinst du also ich würde erwarten dass ab einem gewissen,
intellektuellen niveau der auseinandersetzung der sich jetzt in einem bundesverfassungsgericht voraussetzen würde würde ich schon auch erwarten dass sie halt meine eine kritische frage stellen und zu gucken,
ob
die person in der lage ist das argument aufrecht zu erhalten jetzt kommt natürlich das ist so der rhein inhaltliche teil die frage ne dass seine kritische nachfrage kommt ist ja erstmal ein zeichen von ich habe verstanden was du sagst ich denke mit,
und ich guck mal was du zu folgendem satz eine kritische frage kann ja auch eine vorlage sein also zu.
Oft echt praktisch wirst du richtig wenn die welt erklären dann fragen die eher nach wirklich praktischem nach
wie reduzieren sie denn die die sechsstellige anzahl sozusagen auf auf die wenigen zweihundertsechzig meldungen oder so also richtig praktisch die die wollen auch wissen wie läuft's denn wirklich.
Und dann könnte es dann dann heißt ja immer noch also da ich meine ich will nur sagen damit lässt die pfeife das urteil noch nicht absehen dass man oder eine präferenz der richter nein ich hab schon auch,
klar es gibt ja dann noch den nonverbalen teil
denen auch die richter nicht verheimlichen können der aber zum beispiel natürlich sehr gut wirklich jetzt vorsichtig aus eigener erfahrung das kann ja sehr gut sein,
dass sie sagen,
was weiß ich der wieland hat keine ahnung und das argument war blöd und hier muss ich dir das nochmal erklären das heißt aber nicht unbedingt dass der jetzt dieses verfahren verliert weil es ja trotzdem sein kann dass in den wesentlichen punkten,
er trotzdem aus versehen die richtigen sachen gesagt hat.
Für mich war dieser erste teil dieser zulässigkeit wesentlichen eine nebelkerze,
wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben ja die anhörung findet statt wenn nicht zulässig wäre ja also ich denke der wollte wirklich ein politisches argument machen und vielleicht auch ein bisschen zeit finden jetzt auch möglich weste sodass sie.
Das wird das bundesverfassungsgericht bestimmt super finden wenn dann zeit schilder sitzt.
Ja der der hat halt immer wieder gesagt ja wir können unsere grundrechte nicht auf alle ausländer also der einer der anderen richter hat in diesem begriff verfassungs- realismus geprägt denn die gibt es ja aus wenn wir wir,
benötigen der welt unsere unsere grundrechte auf ja,
weil da ging's ja hin für mich war das für den kern dieses verfahrens nicht weiter wichtig aber da haben die sich vielleicht auch ganz gerne drauf eingelassen,
um ihm was zu entgegnen ich hatte das aber auch wenn du die schriftliche stellungnahme siehst ist nicht der kern der sache.
Gehen wir mal davon aus es wäre eine welt in der.
Aus irgendwelchen gründen wesentliche argumente da jetzt nicht vorgetragen wurden,
von sagen wir von sich aus kommt keine der anwesenden sachverständigen personen auf die idee einen bestimmten punkt anzubringen.
Beispielsweise aus geheimhaltung interessen nicht wissen ja,
das kann gut sein wir reden über den bmw es kann sein dass dort wichtige dinge nicht angesprochen worden weil sie entweder von einer partei nicht gesagt werden dürfen aus geheiratet und gründen oder weil alle technischen sachverständigen sie nicht wissen oder sagen.
Geht es denn zum beispiel gibt's dann auch zum beispiel etwas dass es
das bundesverfassungsgericht dann am ende sagt so jetzt nochmal unter ausschluss der öffentlichkeit also die klassischen nsu-untersuchungsausschuss sachen hier ist der geheimen raum und was es da alles für für scherze gab um.
Na es gibt elemente die mitarbeiter des bmw nicht sagen dürfen weil sie dafür keine aussage niemand haben,
jetzt habe ich aber auch schon früher in verhandlungen erlebt also das also da haben wir einmal mal erlebt beim staatstrojaner dass der präsident des verfassungsschutzes zurückgepfiffen wurden weil er dafür keine aussage nehmen und hatte.
Von seinem eigenen anwalt.
Nee von einem vertreter der behörde der nach vorne sprache und sagt hier hat der präsident keine aussage die mir ist wir reden schon noch immer geheimdienste und natürlich muss man sich auch mal klarmachen du gibst eine technische meinung ab die technischen sachverständigen aber wir können natürlich auch wirklich nur wissen was
wir über öffentliche quellen wissen für mich war sehr sinnvoll,
ich war damals dabei bei der verhandlung beim bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig wo wo einfach 'ne menge erklärt wurde oder dass wir mehr wissen über den sogenannten darf es filter oder geht zehn fitter also was machen die,
ist ja im untersuchungsausschuss zur sprache gekommen aber natürlich wissen oder was zum beispiel in dem bericht von dem stand im sogenannten sonderermittler ja du weißt aber längst nicht alles,
du kannst ja du kannst natürlich immer abstrakt technisch argumentieren,
sicherlich also du kannst erklären wie das netz funktioniert einfach um filtermöglichkeiten zu haben aber bestimmte sachen musst du den glauben wenn die sagen wir haben da mitarbeiter die filter in den kernbereich kannst du technisch nicht weiter zu sagen was kannst du glauben.
Und haben die haben denn die die bundesregierung jetzt die bundesverfassungsrichter noch irgendeine bessere position das zu evaluieren.
Sie hatten zum beispiel die dienste.
Geheime stellungnahme.
Nee aber die können sich akten ziehen zum beispiel können die vom verwaltungsgericht natürlich das einsehen die akten oder sie haben ja auch sehr viele nachfragen gestellt viele der aus dem fragenkatalog waren viele fragen an den bmw bmw.
Das.
Und jetzt wartet auch so mündlich viele fragen sind an den bnd gestellt worden großteil der zeit hat der spd gesprochen und vertreter also technisch oder eben die kontrolleure,
also die die verschiedenen verschiedene kontrollgremien ja nicht nur pkw sondern eben auch diese neue gremium und der datenschutzbeauftragten die sind ja befragt worden,
da reden schon redet schon mehr die beschwerte seite.
Natürlich greifen die beschwerdeführer das immer wieder auf und bringen es auch auf die verfassungsrechtlichen fragen zurück aber praktisch ist natürlich der bnd erstmal gefragt worden,
und davon kannst du ein teil nicht überprüfen du gehst einfach davon aus dass die nicht reist lügen.
Und die richterinnen und richter können das auch nicht überprüfen sie haben keine weiteren.
Na keiner der richter saß jemals zu sagen hat sich den darf es filter angesehen die lesen sich durch die darüber schreiben.
Ist doch eigentlich auch krass oder also ich mein würde man nicht wenn man also.
Bei dem wahlkampf und dann hatten die sich in wahlcomputer bestellt aber sie haben natürlich die kontrollgremien
berichten ja auch also die haben ja auch jeweils in bestimmten abständen berichte und die haben sie ja auch befragt die kontrolleure da kannst du dir natürlich ein bild machen wirklich schon davon aus dass die dich nicht reist belügen.
Ich stelle mir gerade so vor dass sie dann sagen ja okay wir sagen euch mal wir sind hier wirklich läuft aber wenn ihr das in dem urteil erwähnt,
dann verratet ihr ein geheimnis deswegen dürft ihr überhaupt nichts sagen und musst jetzt diese praxis als.
Ich glaube ein teil ist auch für die verfassungsrichter nicht offen wenn zum beispiel also ich gehe jetzt mal die anordnung,
zum beispiel die die jetzt im internet exchange kriegt ihr da sind zum beispiel teilige schmerzen ich denke nicht dass die richter der uni schwarz sehen würde würde ich nicht vermuten,
es war sehr interessant dass diese richterin mal von der praktischen kontrollen die haben sich ja für das gesetz eine neue kontrollinstanz überlegt nämlich drei rechter plus drei stellvertreter und die halt
die hat man so ein bisschen berichtet wie du bist du musst ja mit dem bmw verhandeln dass er dir einblick gibt und wenn du noch nie ein beispiel dafür das war mal interessant aber dann suchen die natürlich die beispiele aus ja das ist so ein bisschen wie
ehemalige parlamentarier über die kontrollinstanzen auch immer über eine märchenstunde gesprochen haben bei der.
Ja was also insbesondere hans-christian ströbele hat ja immer gesagt wenn wir da wenn wir dort hingekommen sind dann saßen wir mit den am tisch und dann haben sie gesagt was wollt ihr denn wissen,
oder wie gesagt was habt ihr denn zu erzählen und dann haben die gesagt nix,
und dann konnten wir die fragen und wenn sie uns wenn am ende rausgekommen ist sie haben uns irgendwas nicht erzählt dann habe ich gesagt ich habe da nicht nachgefragt.
Nun was soll man sehen wir haben darüber nicht.
Nur einmal hat sich haben sich die pkk mitglieder darüber beschwert dass sie den dass sie die sachen die sie anging aus der aus der presse erfahren haben.
Auch die kommission gibt ja noch also im trotzdem würde ich natürlich auch annehmen dass ein teil der also ein teil der aufgaben wie zum beispiel,
schutz von ausländischen standorten der bundeswehr also wir sind nicht im wahnsinn schon dass dass die dort,
dass die dort aufklärung betreiben um diese daten zu schützen ich würde dir nicht bisher jetzt kein teil der märchenstunde es wird halt immer da kritisch wurde auch gesetzwidrigen sein könnte oder im graubereich ist da wird's schwierig oder wenn sie ein fehler machen,
viel viel von den geheimdienst skandal in der vergangenheit haben wir damit zu tun dass geheimdienste fehler machen oder natürlich wenn's um weitergabe von daten geht jetzt mal die drohnen zum beispiel dann da reden wir gleich über leben und tod ja,
muss man.
Okay diese drohnen thematik wo wir die wird dir eigentlich nochmal irgendwo verhandelt oder da ist jetzt fertig mit dem.
Na es laufen wir noch gerichtsverfahren da gibt's ja auch strategische verfahren wo opfer,
in deutschland versuchen die recht durchzusetzen weil ja deutschland beteiligt ist durch die die rammstein airbase also weil ja.
Aber das ist das läuft so insgesamt erstmal also ich weiß es war großes thema im auer aber es dann auch nicht mehr großartig weiter.
Das neue gesetz würde dem nicht entgegenstehen also,
gesetz gibt es keine großen schranken für datenweitergabe und wende die kommunikation zum beispiel von mobiltelefonen die später sozusagen als targets benutzt werden also wo sozusagen der helfer ja drauf fällt dann ist das erstmal,
nicht irgendwie untersagt oder so aber die meisten also so ein paar völkerrechts punkte kam natürlich da auch zur sprache die meisten völkerrechtlich,
sagen ja das ist völkerrechtswidrig also muss man mal sehen ob die haben halt viele von diesen bundeswehr themen und auslandseinsatz themen von vornherein ausgeschlossen weil sie das eben auch gesagt haben das ist nicht unser,
aber man muss sich schon klarmachen dass daten natürlich auch manchmal einfach tote leute bedeuten können das haben wir ja nur gerade erst gesehen,
ich weiß nicht ob ihr den einfluss hatte diese geheimdienst operation dass ein ein zu sagen hut regierungsmitglied in einem fremden land mit einer drohne
ermordet wurde ist natürlich eigentlich wäre hier ja auch ein thema war ja nun mal ein geheimdienste ausführt aber ich glaube dass es im deutschen diskurs spielt nicht so eine große rolle.
Also natürlich könnte theoretisch und praktisch sein dass daten damit zu tun haben aber darüber wissen wir ja nichts.
Daten können damit zu tun haben und die weiterleitung über rammstein aber.
Je hat unzweifelhaft damit zu tun wenn also im im nahen osten operiert wird läuft er immer über rammstein,
aber die bundesregierung steht ja auf dem standpunkt zu sagen also die amerikaner man's versicherte dass alles völker rechtskonform wir haben keinen grund ihn nicht zu glauben.
Die gründe sind ja auch alle tot die können ja.
Man muss schon sehen alle reden immer über den diesen hohen general aber da sind ja auch noch andere menschen tut also die sozusagen wieder drum standen also.
Also die wenigsten leute die die weg drohnen kommen schaffen sie in die nachrichten.
Auch aber also ich kenne keinen namhaften völkerrecht war der nicht für völkerrechtswidrig hält jetzt von den deutschen ist ja jetzt auch wieder argumentiert worden ich meine kamera schau der der jurist der dort sprach hat der der ursache des völkerrechtswidrig,
aber die bundesregierung mauert ja seit vielen jahren obwohl sie ja natürlich weit weit über rammstein läuft.
Es ist ja auch im untersuchungsausschuss aktenkundig geworden.
Gut aber wie gesagt es war nicht wirklich thema hier aber man muss sich natürlich auch schon klar machen dass wir auch nicht nur über theorie reden und
wir reden auch eigentlich nicht nur über journalisten aber es war natürlich der fokus weil die beschwerdeführer darauf sehr abstellen um weil sie sich wünschen dass ein gericht sagt dass man für berufs- geheimnisträger und deren informanten ausnahmen macht dass sie also,
das gesetz kommen.
Ist das realistisch oder technisch realistisch.
Es wird ja nicht darum ob wir technisch realistisch ist wenn es gerichtet sagt müssen sie machen wie sie dann umsetzen servieren eine andere frage aber wenn du jetzt,
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist ja nicht so gering dass journalisten anders behandelt werden dann muss der bmw mehr mitarbeiter die manuell filtern,
anlasslose massenüberwachung an sich beschneidet natürlich werde ich natürlich sehr schön finde.
Was glaubst du also ich denke wir haben jetzt das verfahren in seiner breite gewürdigt.
Oh das ist für viele aspekte also wir können nicht die ganzen stunden und die ganzen argumente die vorher schriftlich aus ich glaube wir haben den kern schon irgendwie getroffen dass der bnd auch ein bisschen,
auf die pauke gar hundert mediale um zu verhindern dass sie da richtig ein reingedreht mitkriegen das ist ja letztlich auch eine drohung,
eine politische zu sagen ja wenn ihr uns blind und taub macht dann werden dann kommt der terror bei uns ist ja.
Das war sehr sehr werte das nochmal der spezifisch.
Schindler und hanning also der ältere bnd-präsidenten.
Nochmal geschrieben aber davon wird sich das bundesverfassungsgericht ja nicht beeindrucken lassen.
Ich glaube nicht dass das gericht in einem in einem luftleeren raum agiert ich glaube dieser zeitgeist,
der hat schon was damit zu tun wie wir alle den geheimdienst sehen und kann da teilweise auch zur sprache ja wie wie kann es sein dass im auftragsprozesse was steht aber die wahrnehmung eine andere ist ja,
und wie kann es sein dass sozusagen
der schuster vom parlamentarischen kontrollgremium zuerst mal den breitscheidplatz nimmt obwohl wir eigentlich über ein auslands nachrichtendienst reden also da gibt's ja so eine gewisse wahrnehmung schere das haben die schon auch angesprochen ich kann mir einfach die zeiten sind,
ich glaube ich nicht die dass man so kritisch derzeit auf geheimdienste blickt die angst potenzial haben die ja natürlich auch selber geschürt.
Ja und das okay dann dann ich hätte jetzt gehofft gedacht dass das das bundesverfassungsgericht ein ort ist der davon unbeeindruckt.
Vielleicht agieren könnte.
Aber das kann ich auch für die anderen verfahren nicht sagen also natürlich
ich würde sagen vor drei jahren wäre das die anders gelaufen wo der jede zweite woche der bmw sich dann bei mir tat wo jede zweite woche was neues in den zeitungen stand über lügen
von geheimdiensten oder über technischen fee technische fähigkeiten das war ja nicht immer der war ja auch
da war glaube ich die kritische öffentlichkeit sind wohnen andere jetzt hat er wieder runtergekommen.
Das heißt dass du würdest jetzt nicht davon ausgehen dass diese verfassungsbeschwerde in gänze ihr ziel erreicht obwohl.
Aber glaube ich noch nie einer oder in gänze.
Ich dachte wahlcomputer und vds hätten das getan.
Nein auch bei der vorratsdatenspeicherung ist umstritten also ich meine da hat sich ja auch die regierung später das war damals auch schäuble nicht irgendwie sagt sie haben's uns ja nicht komplett aus der hand geschlagen wir müssen nur neue gesetz machen das so ist es ja nicht wahlkampf wieder war schon außen.
Hat hat er dann heiko maas auf ihn gemacht am ende.
Also mir scheint auch,
dadurch dass du zu viele verfassungsrechtliche punkte sind der gab ja viele von den regelungen die sich jetzt gedacht haben vorher gar nicht sondern es gab einfach eine praxis die kam raus und dann haben sie ein gesetz gemacht da ist auch viel neuland.
Insofern also ich denke er wird schon ein paar sachen wird es schon geben diese klar gewinnen aber vieles wird so ein jahr aber sein,
würde ich vermuten,
ich bin auch neugierig also sie auch mal durchaus sehr spannend ich werde wenn ich irgendwie kann auch hinfahren zur verkündigung möglicherweise kommt das andere urteil aus straßburg also für die britischen geheimdienste also britische massenüberwachung davor ich würde das vermuten.
Bin ich natürlich auch entspannt das haben die auch erwähnt sind schrift setzen natürlich auch klar und weil er jetzt ja auch der brite da war mal sehen wie der zeitlich wird.
Das verfahren in straßburg hat die konstanze kurz ja in ihrem vortrag nochmal mehr geschildert und ich würde sagen,
nächste mal laden war einfach auch die konstanze ein weil die kann das wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel besser.
Aber bitte nur wein konstanze gewinnt wenn wenn er deine bruchlandung machen das wäre natürlich elend eigentlich wir werden sehen da ist es noch schwerer zu orakeln also jetzt ist aber der eindruck aus karlsruhe und auch frisch.
Und da ist schon auch selten dass er der der bnd so kritisch befragt wird ist ja ist ja schön dass wir so ein gericht haben,
aber man sollte halt finde ich das habe ich auch,
bei dem vortrag jetzt beim kongress der sagt ich finde schon dass wir uns da nicht drauf verlassen sollten ich finde nach wie vor wichtig dass unsere parlamentarier verfassungsgemäß gesetze machen weißt du.
Das wäre nahe dass wir eine schöne sache.
Ich bin findet nicht richtig dass so eine vielzahl von überwachung zu setzen ist die dort landet ich würde mir wünschen dass da die parlamentarier auch vorsichtiger werden.
Na wir werden sehen ich bin gespannt was würdest du denn denken die nuss was rauskommt.
Dafür habe ich tatsächlich zu schlechtes gefühl dafür.
Und wünsch dir was danach wünsch dir was.
Ich muss sogar sagen dass ich noch nicht mal.
Glaube dass ich jetzt zu tief da drin in den letzten jahren rum genörgelt habe als dass ich da jetzt noch eine,
eine emotionale wunschposition habe seine quasi so ein bisschen fast schon selber gespannt bin wie jetzt die waisen leute das entscheiden.
Du hast keine du du hast nichts mehr dir wünschen würdest ob bitte jetzt haben wir ein bisschen.
Nein nein nein natürlich ne es gibt irgendwie klar es gibt die die so ich würde mir natürlich wünschen dass die beschwerden in allen punkten recht bekommen.
Okay.
Das ist das ist klar aber das kann ich jetzt auch irgendwie unter unter berücksichtigung der vielen facetten also ich glaube ich habe so dieses typische weiß jetzt zu viel und kennst die debatte zu lange,
um
um jetzt noch eine einfache lösung dazu zu finden das ist ja fast auch so wie das vermutlich das verfassungsgericht einigen.
Sich sich irgendwie damit auseinandersetzen wird dass sie halt,
alle facetten beachten müssen inklusive was bedeutet diese rechtsprechung für die zukunft und so weiter.
Natürlich ich meine diese verfassungsbeschwerde kommt einfach auch aus meiner heimat aus meiner crew aus meinem background und selbstverständlich würde ich mir,
wünschen dass sie in allen punkten erfolgreich ist ich denke was was mir sorgen macht was mich irgendwie,
eigentlich am meisten beschäftigt ist der teil den du ja eben auch in in stellungnahme und in also in schriftlicher stellungnahme und sicherlich auch in der mündlichen teil den du beigetragen hat halt sagst ist eben dieser.
Dass sämtliche ideen für maß einschränkungen und verfassungsgrundgesetz lagen,
bei paket vermitteln netzwerken überhaupt nicht anwendbar sind das heißt eigentlich müsste.
Eine form der regulierung hier das quasi außen vor lassen,
oder quasi sagen folgendes darf geschehen folgendes darf nicht geschehen und das wäre,
am ende das was du sagst eine filterung für für die sonderrechte träger berufs geheimnisträger und sonstiges das wiederum sieht die technik nicht vor,
das heißt dann am ende wäre es müssten sie es dann mit ihren filterung machen von denen ich grundsätzlich nichts halte weil ich mir ja ich habe ja auch mit daten zu tun,
und insofern ja ich würde mir,
natürlich wünschen dass das alles das all dem einhalt geboten wird dass es eine eine defensivere ausrichtung in der ganzen netzwerk sicherheit und so weiter gibt dass wir auch mal wieder in eine welt kommen in der wir den mut haben
die freiheiten wirklich auch anzuwenden zu leben und zu verteidigen und freiheiten werden eben nicht verteidigt indem sie eingeschränkt werden.
Wo du jetzt selber sagst dann muss ich sie ja noch argument von dem dfb-präsidenten bringen weil durch die strategische ausland ausland fern bei der aufklärung können sie ja cyberangriffe attribute.
Ja okay und wenn dann so ein wünsche ich einfach nur eine schmach volle niederlage weil das halt ein ein ne das ist finale rettungsschutz wie wie david so schön sagte.
David krise dessen vortrag wie immer empfehlen können ja ich wollte dir eben wusste nur nochmal sagen.
Was wäre was war das schönste wort was du bestellst dann haben wir auch einen sendung titel.
Ich fand es sehr griffig man muss sich das klarmachen die generieren bestellzettel.
Also ich finde das sehr schön das ist doch also ganz ernsthaft hast du den begriff vorher schon mal gehört.
Naja im untersuchungsausschuss viel fehlt ja so viel ja sowas auch mal aber ich fand auch also wann immer noch ein paar mehr sachen die wohl echt
also zum beispiel wenn jemand wie der präsident ein appell an die richter richtet und doch so nennt,
das war der vertreter der der bundesregierung der bilanz also er möchte einen appell an die richter was schlagt uns das nicht aus der hand so gut fand ich schon bemerkt wird also da waren ein paar sachen so aber mir mir ist dieser bestellzettel,
deshalb auch sehr aufgefallen weil eben es wurde viel vermischt zwischen suchbegriffe die als filter dienen und suchbegriffe die man generiert und diese schöpfen aus den daten massen das fehlt oft so ein bisschen unter den tisch.
Ich hätte jetzt bei dem begriff,
bestellzettel so ein bisschen gedacht dass sie den strategisch gewählt haben um weil der so nach nach behörde nach ablauf nach der bestellzettel wird abgezeichnet,
und dann tun wir den im prozess rein dann kommt er in den ordner und dann wieder gestempelt und ohne stempel ist ja nicht gültig und.
Klingt doch irgendwie analog ne klingt nicht nach nach tausenden.
Genau klingt so analog du hast du hast du hast eine wahnsinnige überwachungs- strukturen und sagt dann so dann dann haben wir ein bestellzettel am ende haben wir wahrscheinlich noch eine bedarfs prüfung unten und ein budget und also,
dieses schöne.
Klingt nicht nach nach millionen daten setzen sondern er klingt immer klingt irgendwie viel weniger ich fand den begriff.
Ja das ist ein das wäre ein begriff für den für neu sprech ehrlich gesagt weil ich nicht glaube dass da irgendwie hast du den bestätigt nein und den lieferschein haben wollen wir denn jetzt die lieferscheine wieder wenn wir die lieferscheine nicht haben.
Wir haben einmal gefragt wieviel dieser bestellzettel dann sozusagen gibt und die anzahl ist natürlich dann auch wieder sechsstellig also so eine art wüsste aber der der begriff klingt nicht danach,
ich fand es auch interessant,
aber generell wenn die vertreter haben natürlich so ein bisschen warm spreche immer also merkst du deswegen heißt er auch ausland ausland fernmeldeamt aufklärung und eben nicht massenüberwachung sie haben halt andere begriffe.
Ja ja natürlich haben die andere begriffe aber ich hoffe ja dass ich da niemand von täuschen lässt und wenn die wenn die jeden einzelnen bestellzettel da ausdrucken dann kriegen sie auch ärger mit fridays for future.
Was steht auf dem bestellt steht da personenbezogene datum,
steht da eine region steht da eine lokation wie die frage ist ja und so konkret natürlich nicht besprochen worden
meine vorstellung ist technik ist norwegen eine andere wird da draufsteht wenn ich weiß ich habe ja im hinterkopf sozusagen den begriff so lektor als man sonst mit bestellzettel verbinden würde.
Naja.
Glaubst du die haben so eine ich glaube sie haben die leute die dann sagen sie hier nimm mal den begriff der klingt schön steif oder so.
Also man hat sicherlich gemerkt an den präsidenten der die reden ja alle so ein bisschen ja mal so ein diplomaten sprechen also viel sagen und nicht sagen vor allen dingen nichts zu den verfassungsrechtlichen vorwürfen ist hat er auch gemacht aber.
Aber das müsste doch bei so einem.
Mitarbeiter nicht.
Das ist mein eindruck zumindest also die haben auch sich teilweise rumdrückt also.
Ich fand es sehr interessant dass die juristen vom bmw haben gleich mehrere gesprochen dann auch immer wieder verweisen auf ihre technische mitarbeiter danach dann sprechen und aber dann wieder nichts sagen zu der frage die die richter,
da kommt schon mal vor ja oder dass sie eben,
filter beschrieben haben die sie zukünftig einsetzen wollen also so eine gezielte magie genannt die also die sollen dann mal funktionieren
hatten sie eine auch eine mitarbeiterin des bnd dieses hat kurz beschrieben und dann am ende sagte sie aber ja bei noch sind die gar nicht im einsatz so eine idee,
hier mal vorstellen und mich hat es auch geärgert dass.
Man müsste ja die kontrolle genauso machen man müsste ja auch technisch näher bestimmen wie man kontrolliert im gesetz steht geht es einmal um stichproben ist natürlich albern ja bei millionen daten setzen und wir,
also wie wie siehst denn du so eine stichprobe und so also da auch die ebene der kontrolle hat er wieder.
Ja das ist das ist echt schön dass das noch anspruchsvoll das wäre wirklich diese also es wäre ja nicht also man könnte viel kontrolle,
darüber gut hinbekommen indem man einfach ein sauberes kontrollrad regime definiert und wie die daten dafür erfasst werden ja dass man sagt dass nämlich die kontrolle.
So blöd das ist konnte die kontrolle so unvorhersehbar ist wie möglich,
damit nämlich die kontrolle genau unter die kontrolle nämlich nicht gegart werden kann dass du weißt okay es gibt einfach eine wahrscheinlichkeit von mit den mit der anzahl der daten die wir erfassen
steigt die anzahl der daten die kontrolliert die erfasst werden und kontrolliert werden und die anzahl der daten die kontrolliert werden die,
ergibt sich zufällig und für jeden verstoß kriegen wir richtig offen sagt und,
so hast du halt ne wenn du wenn du irgendwie so ein die alten ideen der pkk diese eigentlich wo du klar weiß der kontrolleur kommt das gehen wir wieder lecker essen,
so ne dann ist natürlich auch klar dass der dass der rechtsbruch die rechts beugung und so sehr sehr nahe liegen das scheint ja auch.
Das fehler vertuscht werden muss ja nicht immer absichtlich sein kann ja unabsichtlich sein also hab ich auch ich habe aus versehen ein telefon sexgespräche transkribiert ja das muss ja nicht immer absicht sein dann könnt ihr auch einfach passieren weil mein fazit war so schlecht,
na ja was ist auch kontexte hatte die eine kontrollieren und kontrolleure natürlich auch gut erklärt wie du eine pn meldung stichprobe und beispiel kriegst das heißt das noch lange nicht dass du so einschätzen kannst ja da fehlt dir der,
teilweise der kontext also das ist natürlich auch nicht so leicht und dann dürfen die kontrolleure nicht miteinander kommunizieren die sind ja wieder alle beschränkt weil sie bei dir geheimwissen ist,
könnte man sich ja zum beispiel mit dem bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten austauschen der ja auch wieder kontrolliert oder mit bist du so also da gibt's schon eine menge probleme insofern war das schon ganz klug,
dass sie sich den briten als anderen beispiel mal eingeladen haben um sich zu überlegen wie machen sie denn andere ja,
mal sehen also ich denke der kern des urteils wird die kontrolle nicht sein,
ich finde das natürlich aber bei massenhaften technischen verfahren eigentlich sehr viel.
Das wäre das was ich mir wünschen würde ja.
Ich habe kurz angesprochen aber dafür ist doch gar kein ansatz denn,
so wie die jetzt einen dienstvorschrift haben sie haben die halt keine für wir lassen technisch sinnvolle kontrolle zu.
Und das glaube ich lässt sich schon sein dass wir ja eigentlich unsere wichtigste forderung eine die die kontrolle ist der teil der am ende,
wenn er vernünftig wirkt die da auch das einhalten der regeln überhaupt sicherstellen kann.
Und die weitergabe also wenn wenn du jetzt auch dann die weitergabe mit decks natürlich,
ich bin natürlich trotzdem immer noch ein vertreter davon dass eine anders soße massenüberwachung für mich keine zukunftsträchtige idee ist ich würde immer unterbinden wollen weil,
für falsch halten aber,
wenn du davon wenn du zumindest teilweise zulässt dann musst du wenigstens die schranken kontrollieren können ich musste nicht nur ins gesetz zu schreiben finde ich ich glaube einfach dass die geheimdienste in der vergangenheit immer wieder bewiesen haben dass sie sich nicht an die,
regeln halten die ihn gemacht worden oder sie zumindest die lücken aussuchen,
einfach weil sie vielleicht auch praktisch arbeiten wollen oder weil sie einfach schlampig arbeiten wie auch immer sehr egal ich finde wer im geheimen angeht muss besonders stark kontrolliert sein das ist eine haltung die ich schon lange vertrete und das an,
zu sagen,
zum zweiten verhandlungstag unser bundespräsident da gerade bei der stasi zentrale seine feierliche rede hält und die mutigen ddr-bürger,
wertschätzt die diese geheimdienst gestürmt haben würde gerne auf die demokratischen,
prozesse die unsere geheimdienste hier kontrollieren sollen übertragen ja man braucht auch den mut den regeln zu machen weil selber machen die sich keiner und dazu musst du sie kontrollieren und ich hoffe dass du dort halt dazu beiträgt also,
mal sehen.
Das ist doch ein schönes schlusswort.
Na ja das auch ich werde nicht zu stark vergleichen also ich denke schon dass,
der andere ist in statt sicherheit redet aber dennoch,
gerade dieser geheimnisse hat man auch an der verhandlung gemerkt tritt schon auch recht einfach ja.
Treten einfach in der weise auf die fühlen sich sozusagen für,
die sicherheit der ganzen republik als unerlässlich und sagen sie auch immer wieder und das finde ich eine.
Fühle ich mich aber ehrlich gesagt auch.
Ich finde.
Na ja also die die die fühlen sich schon also sehr sehr doll wichtig ist eben so naja aber so ist das eben heutzutage.
Das heißt es wird aber um das thema jetzt wieder still und wird ein paar.
Nö nö wir haben noch ein verfahren du bist ja beim bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig hattet nicht geendet sondern das ist auch in karlsruhe anhängig,
ja also,
wird schon noch mehr kommen und wir haben bin ich darin einander vom europäischen menschenrechts gerichtshof die frage auch und gestern die nachricht beim eugh habe trifft er auch die massenüberwachung und teilweise eben auch von geheimdiensten also da sind wir schon noch auf mehreren ebenen am start.
Ich meinte jetzt dieses spezifische verfahren aber die anderen erwähnten möchten wir natürlich auch und auch das urteil des eugh werden wir in der nächsten sendung dann behandeln.
Und menschenrechte richtet auch.
Ja machen wir auch machen wir alles.
Alle wir müssen immer alle berichten.
Und damit hoffen wir ein.
Einblick bisschen da reingegeben zu haben erstens wie dieses verfahren verlaufen ist was wie es darum ging wir haben oder ich habe auch viel wert darauf gelegt weil mich das auch interessiert wie es dann so vor ort war wie das da so ist,
konnte leider nicht da sein und das hätte mich wollte ich mal so freue ich mich dass wir das heute in dieser sendung mal ein bisschen in ruhe,
aufrollen konnten wie gesagt nächstes mal lieber tim lass uns das von der konstanze kurz direkt erklären.
Also ich habe auch meine stimme lieber linus wird bald besser.
Und damit sind wir am ende der sendung angelangt und ich wünsche.
Uns allen eine überwachungs- die zukunft.
Da bin ich dabei tschau tschau.
Tschau tschau.